[Musique]
Frédéric Pirouci, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
vous recevons dans le cadre de votre
activité en tant que peut-être
industrielle ou dans votre activité de
Halstom
qui a été Halstom et puis peut-être
votre expérience en prison aux
États-Unis en quartier de haute
sécurité. Comment ça va ? Ça va très
bien. Ça va beaucoup mieux qu' 8 mois,
on va dire. Je suis revenu en France en
septembre 2018 après à peu près 25 mois
dans les prisons américaine. Donc ça va
beaucoup mieux. Ça va beaucoup mieux.
Pourquoi vous êtes pourquoi vous avez
atterri en prison ?
Alors c'est une longue histoire. J'étais
j'ai fait 22 ans chez Alstom. J'étais
directeur commercial de plusieurs
filiales. J'ai été patron de plusieurs
business chez Alstom.
Combien ça gagne ?
Combien ça gagne ? Ça gagne aux
alentours de 200000 € à peu près.
Ça fait 20000 netes.
Ouais, peut-être un peu moins quoi. Un
peu moins. Un peu moins. À l'époque
lorsqu'on était expat, ça valait un peu
un peu mieux. Tout dépend des pays
d'expatriation. Donc j'étais expatrié
pendant près une 18 ans à peu près aux
quatre coins du monde. Chine 6 ans, aux
États-Unis 7 ans, euh dans Algérie, en
en Angleterre. Et donc mon dernier
poste, j'étais patron d'une filiale euh
d'un business qui faisait 4000
personnes, un milliard quatre de chiff
d'affaires. à l'époque la stratégie du
groupe Alstom. Alors, Alstom, je
voudrais rappelle à l'époque he parce
que beaucoup de gens ont peut-être déjà
oublié, c'était à une partie, c'était
les transports, les trains, les TGV et
les métros et ensuite il y avait toute
la partie toute la partie production
d'électricité et transport
d'électricité, donc les centrales
charbon, les centrales hydrauliques, les
centrales nucléaires. Et donc moi,
j'étais patron d'une d'une grosse
division qui était la division chudière.
Et euh à l'époque, la stratégie du
groupe Alsom était euh de se rapprocher
euh des Chinois sur la toute la partie
euh production d'énergie parce que la
plupart du marché était euh en Asie dans
les pays émergents. Et donc euh ça avait
été annoncé en 2010-211 que euh ma
division allait être la division qui
allait servir comme de test à ce
rapprochement entre Alstom et donc son
concurrent chinois qui s'appelait
Shangil électrique.
sur la partie transport, l'idée du PDG
l'époque était de faire rentrer les
Russes au capital de la partie
transport.
Les Américains ont apprécié.
Les Américains ont apprécié bien
évidemment. Donc euh moi pendant 2 ans,
j'ai fait tout le découpage de de mes
unités à pas partout dans le monde. J'ai
transféré le siège de euh de ma division
de Paris à Singapour qui devait être le
siège de de la société commune avec nos
amis de Chang Chang électrique qui était
une société à 5050. Euh j'avais été
choisi comme le futur patron de cette de
cette entité commune par le PDG d'Alstom
et le PDG de Changil électrique. Et donc
j'ai amené monsieur Cron. Voilà. Et donc
j'ai amené toute ma famille là-bas euh
en août 2012.
Et euh ben 3 mois après mon arrivée à
Singapour, j'ai été mis en examen par le
ministère de la justice américaine, donc
le département de justice en novembre
2012 euh pour avoir participé à des
faits de corruption qui dataaient de
200300.
Participer dans quel sens ? Alors euh ce
que le procureur m'a reproché, c'était
euh d'être au courant qu'Alstom avait
embauché des consultants qui avaient euh
très certainement payé des pots de vin à
l'époque de de ce contrat.
Qui qui qui chez Halstom a engagé ses
consultants ?
Alors chez Alstom euh en 20032004, il y
avait des procédures extrêmement
strictes pour sélectionner des
consultants.
Nous avions organisation matricielle,
les business d'un côté, l'international
de l'autre. Il fallait pas moins de 13
signatures euh pour embaucher euh le
moindre consultant. Euh deux des deux
surignatures euh les plus élevées étant
deux personnes qui rapportaient
directement au patron euh du groupe.
Donc euh je
jeouv juste une parenthèse. Dans ces 13
signatures, est-ce que le qu d'orsais
faisait partie de la boucle ?
Est-ce que la DGSE faisait partie de la
boucle ?
Non, parce que jusqu'à l'an 2000, les
entreprises françaises allaient déclarer
à Beril les pot de vin. D'accord. et
c'était même exonéré de l'impôt sur les
sociétés.
À partir de l'an 2000, la France a dû
suivre les règles de l'OCDE qui imposait
à ce que il une législation française
qui empêche la corruption d'agent public
étranger. Donc à partir de l'an 2000,
beaucoup de groupes français se ont mis
en place des procédures de compéence à
l'intérieur des l'intérieur de de leur
entreprise et donc Alstom a fait a fait
le même. Donc à partir de l'an 2000, en
théorie, les entreprises françaises
n'ont plus le droit de faire de la
corruption à l'étranger. En tout cas,
ils n'ont plus le droit de c'est c'est
c'est répréhensible pénalement en
France. Donc euh à l'époque, Alom a mis
en place ses procédures et donc il
fallait pas moins je vous dis de 13 13
procédures pour simplement approuver la
signature d'un consultant et ensuite
pour le payer si on avait gagné
l'affaire parce que tous ces consultants
étaient payés en fait au succès ou pas
de de de l'opération. Euh pareil
tout dépend. Il y avait chez Hstom en
théorie, il y avait un un cap à 6 à 3.
Il y avait un cap à 3 % euh normalement
ou 3 millions de dollars.
Mais bon, ça ça pouvait ça pouvait
varier. Dans ce contrat en Indonésie,
euh en fait, il y avait eu deux contrats
de consultant, un contrat à 1 % et un
contrat à 2 %.
Donc à l'époque, moi j'étais patron
commercial d'une filiale
et donc dans mes fiches de prix, j'avais
une ligne consultant et effectivement je
savais que Alstom avait avait pris des
consultants. Juste pour vous raconter
quand même la petite histoire parce que
ça c'est intéressant. Euh à l'époque, en
2003, on remet une offre en Indonésie
pour construire une centrale une
centrale électrique. Nous sommes en
concurrent en concurrence avec un une
entreprise américaine.
L'ouverture des prix, nous sommes les
moins les moins 10 ans. Euh
ensuite s'ouvre une période d'évaluation
qui dure à peu près 6 mois. Euh pendant
cette période d'évaluation euh les
Américains arrivent à retourner le
comité d'évaluation en graissant la pâte
un peu à tout le monde. Et
bon, on a les preuves à l'époque, c'est
ce que c'est ce que le client nous a
dit, enfin ce que ce que le client a dit
à nos à nos à nos représentants en
Indonésie en disant que voilà les
Américains avaient réussir à retourner
le le comité d'évaluation et que euh le
comité d'éviation allait recommander que
le projet soit attribué à cette
entreprise américaine. Et sauf si euh on
travaillait avec un consultant que que
le patron de le DF local avait désigné à
notre représentant local.
Et donc c'est c'est ce qui s'est fait.
Euh
toute toute la toute la hiérarchie
d'Alstom a prouvé que ce consultant soit
soit embauché,
compris monsieur Cron.
Euh bah jusqu'au plus niveau à l'époque,
c'était jusqu'au niveau juste juste en
dessous de lui des deux signatures. Euh
et donc
ce ce consultant est embauché, le comité
d'habation été retourné et on a on a
gagné le contrat. Donc ce qui m'ont
reproché les Américains, c'était ce
qu'ils appellent d'avoir enfin s'appelle
willful blindness en anglais, c'est en
gros d'avoir fait l'autruche, c'est
d'avoir de savoir que Alstom avait
embauché des des deux consultants sans
vouloir savoir ce que ce que ces
consultants allaient faire de de leur
argent. Et donc pour eux, c'est comme si
vous aviez vous-même apporté la valise
de cash dans les mains d'un d'un
officiel indonésien. Et donc sur ce
principe là, il pouvait mettre en examen
des dizaines et des dizaines de de de
personnes d'employés dans le groupe.
Vous risquez 15 ans.
Alors, si on reprend le
chronologiquement ce qui s'est passé,
euh je voyageais très régulièrement aux
États-Unis, donc j'avais à peu près 700
personnes là-bas à aller voir. Donc
lorsque je suis allé aux États-Unis en
avril 2013, en arrivant à l'aéroport de
de Kennedy,
la porte s'est ouverte et donc j'ai eu
un comité d'accueil avec des agents du
FBI qui m' me noté, qui m'ont fait
tracer tout l'aéroport comme ça, qui
m'ont mis dans une voiture banalisée et
qui m'ont emmené au siège du FBI à
Manhattan.
Et là, j'ai été reçu par ce un procureur
euh qui m'a dit "Bah voilà, Alstom est
sous enquête du département de justice
depuis plus de 3 ans euh pour des
affaires de corruption. Alors, il y
avait l'Indonésie mais il y en avait
tout un tas à d'autres. Euh
en gros, Alstom se fout de nous. Ils
disent qu'il coopère mais en fait il ne
coopère pas. Et donc, nous avons perdu
patience.
Notre but est de mettre en prison le CEO
du du groupe,
Cron.
Monsieur Cron. Mais pour ça, on a besoin
de de votre aide. Déjà un, on a voulu
leur passer le message que en vous
arrêtant que maintenant c'était sérieux
et de on a besoin de votre aide. Et donc
il me propose en fait à demi de jouer la
top à l'intérieur de l'entreprise.
Euh alors là vous c'est ça se passe très
rapidement. Vous devez répondre dans les
dans dans les 2 secondes qui suit.
Qué la question.
Ben la question c'est ça. N'appelez pas
votre ambassade, n'appelez pas votre
votre entreprise euh va le savoir.
Voilà. Et et donc vous avez le droit
mais ne le faites pas parce qu'on veut
vous fassiez des choses pour nous. Et
donc là tout de suite je réagis, moi je
dis non je je veux appeler moi mon
entreprise, je veux appeler mon mon
ambassade pour leur dire que je viens
d'être arrêté.
Euh alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
d'autres personnes à l'intérieur du
groupe ont joué les tops pendant des
années. C'estàd top ça veut dire
assister à tous les rendez-vous à tous
les tous les meetings avec un micro
autour du coup et enregistrer tout ce
qui se passait. À quel niveau de
responsabilité la taupe était ?
C'est pas clair. Je ne je sais pas. J'ai
entendu des des enregistrements mais il
y en a eu plusieurs certainement.
Américains qui vous ont fait entendre
les enregistrements ?
Ouais. Cétait ça faisait partie de de ce
qu'ils appellent les évidences, les
preuves contre contre le groupe. Donc
j'ai entendu certains certains de de ces
enregistrements
qui disaient quoi ? Mais en fait, c'est
c'est des gens qui qui allaient dans
comme vous moi qui allaient dans dans
des réunions et qui enregistraient
simplement les les euh les dir euh dans
toutes ces réunions. Ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre, c'est que lorsque vous êtes
français et qu'on vous fa ce genre de
proposition, euh vous allez réagir de
manière négative. Lorsque vous êtes
américain et que vous connaissez le
système de justice américain, on vous
fait ce genre de proposition. vous allez
écouter et surtout vous allez
certainement certainement le faire euh
parce que les Américains connaissent le
département de connaissent la façon dont
on dont on dont il travaille et savent
très bien que de toute façon il y a pas
il y a pas d'autres solution au bout du
compte si on veut s'en sortir avec une
peine une peine minimale.
Pourquoi je vous coupe ? Ouais.
Pourquoi ne pas avoir fait oui avec la
tête en disant oui oui, je vais jouer la
taupe ? Rentrer à Paris, filer au qued
d'Or, aller chercher les gars de la GCO
en disant voilà les gars, on a un
problème, on est infiltré
euh euh on a des taupes partout, vous
avez pas fait votre travail pour lever
les toupes.
Il me propose ça. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Est-ce que je fais le double ? Est-ce
que je fais le trip ? Vous savez, on on
prend une décision en une fraction de
seconde. Donc donc j'ai très franchement
j'étais extrêmement surpris déjà d'être
arrêté. Je savais même pas pourquoi
j'étais j'étais arrêté.
Et ça c'est une discussion qui se passe
en en en 30 secondes.
Je effectivement si réflexion faite
peut-être que j'aurais dû faire ça mais
je suis je sais qu'ils sont pas idiot
aussi de l'autre côté qui ne m'auraient
certainement pas laissé repartir en
France sans sans sans une certaine forme
de garantie. Et je vous verrez après
dans mon histoire que ils ont su me me
tenir pendant plus de 5 ans et
m'empêcher de parler pendant plus de 5
ans. Donc ils sont pas ils sont pas B je
vous on va y arriver mais on va je
voudrais vous poser une question mais là
c'est c'est plus purement
franco-français. H
les services de renseignement ils sont
censés protéger nos actifs stratégiques.
Vous êtes d'accord avec moi ? Je sais
parce que on a aussi un réseau que la
DGSE se balade un peu partout dans les
boîtes ou met des hommes à eux à la tête
de boîte pour soit encaisser les
manœuvres de corruption, soit encaisser
les manœuvres de la mafia par exemple en
Asie. Ça se fait beaucoup.
Vous confirmez ? Vous avez déjà entendu
parler de ça ?
Entendu parler de ça. Oui.
D'accord.
Est-ce que vous vous avez été approché
par les services pour faire une petite
formation en terme de sécurité
informatique, en terme de de pression
que les services extérieurs étrangers
pouvaient vous faire ? Est-ce que votre
équipe a été sensibilisée par ce type de
de formation ou pas du tout ou ils vous
ils vous ont laissé dans la nature à 100
% ?
En 22 ans chez Astom, on a eu jamais eu
de formation sur l'intelligence
économique, sur on a jamais eu de
contact direct avec les de la DGSE. Non,
on a eu rien eu et pourtant j'ai j'ai
occupé des des des postes extrêmement
exposés. J'étais pendant 6 ans directeur
des ventes en Chine par exemple dans les
années 90. J'ai ensuite je suis parti 7
ans aux États-Unis dans des fonctions
similaires. On n' jamais eu un seul une
seule formation.
En terme de sécurité informatique,
pareil, ils vous ont jamais expliqué
qu'un téléphone portable laissait
patronner par terre des choses comme ça
pareil pareil pareil. Ils vous ont
jamais expliqué le principe des [__]
des tapins, des soirées un peu arrosées,
des choses comme ça.
On entend parler mais il y en a jamais
eu de formation sur ces sur ces
sujets-là. Jamais.
Jamais.
C'est bizarre quand même.
Mais je crois qu'il y a une énorme
naïveté de toute façon dans les dans les
entreprises françaises. Alors un peu
moins maintenant mais euh bien
évidemment il y a je pense que nos nos
homologues dans dans d'autres
entreprises internationales notamment
américaines sont extrêmement formés à ce
genre de choses. Les Chinois pareil, les
Japonais encore plus euh mais les Russes
bien évidemment. Mais euh non, on a moi
je n'ai jamais eu euh de formation et
pourtant j'étais euh en première ligne
sur sur beaucoup de sujets extrêmement
sensibles euh en tant que en tant que
directeur commercial. Euh je je à
l'époque j'ai été pendant plus de 6 ans
aussi euh en charge de la vente des
centrales clé en main charbon et euh des
idos conventionnelles de central
nucléaire. Donc c'est quand même des
sujets un peu un peu non jamais jamais
aucune formation. Donc si si je reviens
peut-être au déroulé si vous permettez.
Donc à partir du moment où je dis que je
ne que je souhaite appeler mon
entreprise, donc je réveille en pleine
nuit le directeur juridique du groupe
qui lui s'apprêtait à venir aux
États-Unis, me dit "Ben écoutez, je
comprends pas pourquoi tu es arrêté
Fred, on coopère avec le département of
justice. Euh je me réveille moi-même
pour prendre l'avion, pour aller à
Washington pour aller assister à la
négociation finale avec avec nos amis
américains. Et donc bah tu vas passer
une mauvaise nuit en prison là. Mais
demain,
tu vas être présenté devant un juge. On
va demander ta libération sous caution.
Vous savez, aux États-Unis, pratiquement
tout le monde est libéré sous caution.
Madof a été libéré sous caution pendant
plusieurs semaines. Oj Simpson a été
libéré sous caution pendantcan.
Voilà. Euh donc on on va te on va te
mettre un avocat top et euh et tu seras
libéré sous caution et ensuite tu
reviens à la maison et on va régler ça
en famille. Alors, je passe cette
première nuit effectivement en prison à
Manathan. Le lendemain, on me réveille
et on m'amène devant devant un juge dans
Bridgeeport dans le Connecticut.
Et là, le procureur le même que j'avais
vu la veille se lance dans une diatribe
contre Alstom, contre la France. Il fait
référence notamment à DSK. DSK en
disant, on a fait une erreur à l'époque,
on va pas le refaire. La France
n'extrate pas ses ressortissants. Donc
monsieur Pierouci, même si on le met
dans un appartement avec des gardes 24/
24/ 7, euh même si on lui met un brass
électronique au pied, même si on lui
prend son passeport, euh il y a une
chance qu'il qu'il s'échappe. Euh pour
j'étais devenu James Bond hein, il y a
c'est une chance qu'il s'échappe et
qu'il revienne en France. À partir du
moment où il revient en France, on
narrivera pas à le à le rattraper et on
va perdre le cas contre lui. Mais aussi
on risque de perdre le cas contre Alum.
Nous avons investi des dizaines de
millions de dollars d'enquête sur Alstom
depuis plus de 3 ans avec des des
dizaines d'agents du FBI qui ont
travaillé sur sur le cas et nous pouvons
pas nous permettre de prendre le moindre
risque. Donc la magistrate est convaincu
par la par les dir de du procureur et
donc décide de ne pas de pas me ler
lirer sous caution. Donc là, c'est
vraiment le début du euh
du cauchemar, hein, parce que là, à
partir de ce moment-là, on met des
chaînes au pieds, on met des chaînes aux
mains, des chaînes autour du torse, euh
on me met dans un fourgon blindé comme
vous voyez à la télévision là et euh
direction prison de haute sécurité euh
dans le Road Island. Alors, bon, j'ai
appris, il y a quatre niveaux de
sécurité dans les prisons américaines.
On me met directement au au plus haut
niveau de sécurité.
Donc là, vous arrivez dans un rendement
euh pas très facile euh avec ce qu'on
appelle des criminels de carrière. Donc
des gens qui ont passé 10 ans, 15 ans,
20 ans, 30 ans et qui pour beaucoup ne
sortiront jamais de prison. Euh donc on
me laisse croupir là pendant pendant
plusieurs jours. Euh d'abord dans une
cellule de 4 et assez rapidement dans un
dortoir de 54 personnes.
Donc lumière 24h/ 24, ça sur 7. euh
des des conditions d'hygiène assez assez
assez recambolaes quand même, des des
toilettes sans porte, sans mur, des
douches des douches communes et cetera.
Et on vous laisse pour ir là quoi. Alors
très rapidement, je demande
est-ce que quelqu'un d'om vient de me
rencontrer ? Euh alors, il y a pas
beaucoup de volontaires, vous imaginez,
qui soient prêt à prendre l'avion. Donc
je demande notamment au directeur
juridique KFCAR qui était à Washington
de venir me voir. Bien sûr personne ne
vient.
Donc là dès le début je sens que on va
me laisser tomber et ça et ça arrive
très rapidement.
Le qui dorsais toujours pas
ah lequet il alors j'ai appelé le le
consul là le jour de mon arrestation.
Ensuite, comme j'avais été arrêté à New
York et qu'ils m'ont mis dans un dans le
Rod Island qui dépendait de Boston, ils
ont mis à peu près 15 jours, 3 semaines
avant de me retrouver quoi. Euh avant de
prendre contact avec moi.
Donc euh donc euh
pendant cette cette période là en tout
cas les les premiers jours, mon avocat
vient me voir. que alors l'avocat ancien
attorné général du Connecticut donc
quand même qui était de l'autre côté de
la barrière avant qui était le patron du
DOJ dans le Connecticut pendant pendant
plusieurs années. Donc je me dis le gars
c'est un cador, il va il va réussir à me
sortir de là. Bon, sauf que il ne
connaissait rien à la loi pour laquelle
j'avais arrêté qui s'appelle le Foreign
Corpor Practice Act FCPA euh que dès le
début j'ai compris qu'il
qu'il ne me défendait pas vraiment et je
vais revenir je vais revenir dessus
et en fait j'ai fait une énorme erreur
parce que
l'entreprise a a trouvé cet avocat et me
l'a me l'a un peu imposé. On me l'a
imposé. En fait, au début, j'étais très
content. Je me suis dit tiens,
l'entreprise s'occupe de moi, elles
sommes s'occupent de moi, elles vont ils
vont me trouver ils m'ont trouvé un
avocat qui est qui est top en tout cas
sur le papier. Euh et très rapidement,
je me suis aperçu qu'en fait cet avocat
était payé par l'avocat qui défendait
Alstom dans le même cas. Euh donc
conflit d'intérêt énorme. Je comprends
même pas maintenant avec le recul
comment cet avocat a pu euh accepter de
de me défendre. Il envoyait tout c'est
toutes les semaines ces notes de frais
extrêmement détaillées à l'avocat
d'Alstom qui le payait. Et alors que euh
dès le début, ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre, vous avez un conflit intégré
énorme entre l'entreprise et euh
l'employé parce que l'employé ce qu'il
veut c'est euh un démontrer que il
n'était qu'un qu'un qu'un petit maillon
dans dans la chaîne d'approbation. Donc
vous demandez des copies d'email, vous
demandez des copies de de de
de d'organisation de charte, vous
demandez euh des rapports dans le dans
dans ce dans ce cas précis, il y avait
eu un rapport d'audit qui avait été fait
par un cabinet d'avocat américain qui
avait auditionné ce contrat en Indonésie
et qui avait conclu que que j'étais
innocent. Donc j'ai demandé une copie de
ce rapport. Je savais que ce rapport
existait euh mais bien sûr l'entreprise
ne me l'a jamais fourni. Euh alors ce
qui ce qui est compréhensible de notre
côté parce que euh donc lorsque vous
êtes l'entreprise, ce que vous ne voulez
pas c'est c'est euh vous ne voulez pas
mettre en danger les autres cadres. Donc
si vous demandez des euh si le cadre
arrêté demande des copies d'email, des
copies de de SMS, euh des des rapports
et cetera qui forcément mettent en cause
des gens plus haut dans la hiérarchie,
lorsque vous êtes patron de
l'entreprise, vous n'allez surtout pas
donner ça à votre employé pour qu'il
puisse se se défendre. Et donc le
conflit d'intérêt est immédiat immédiat
et donc euh le problème c'est
effectivement que c'était mon avocat
travaillait pour la partie adverse. Mais
ça je ça j'ai réalisé beaucoup beaucoup
plus tard si vous voulez. Au début
j'étais extrêmement content. Donc euh
ils m'ont laissé pourrir pendant
plusieurs semaines en fait dans dans
cette dans cette prison et euh au bout
de à peu près un mois euh j'ai eu la
visite du procureur euh qui m'a dit la
chose suivante. Voilà, vous avez en gros
vous avez deux choix.
Soit vous décidez euh d'aller au procès
et si vous décidez d'aller au procès,
vous allez rester dans cette prison de
votre sécurité jusqu'au jour de votre
procès.
Euh ça entre-temps, j'avais demandé
trois fois d'être libéré sous caution.
Ils m'ont refusé les trois fois. Euh
vous on va vous on va vous donner à vos
avocats euh toutes les preuves qu'on a
collecté contre le groupe Alstom. Donc
il y avait à peu près 1 million et demi
de pièces en tout cas dans un premier
batch. Euh alors c'était des des emails,
des SMS, des des copies de rapport et
cetera.
Merci la NSA.
Merci la NSA et tous les services
américains qui avaient travaillé dessus.
Donc donc ces fameux enregistrements
faisaient partie aussi de de ces 1
million et demi de pièces.
Et euh si vous voulez euh aller jusqu'au
procès, si vous perdez votre procès, euh
c'est 15 ans.
Voilà, on a un mot bouquin qui s'appelle
US qui définit les peines de prison en
fonction des crimes. Alors, c'est pour
harmoniser ça dans tous les États des
États-Unis pour ces crimes fédéraux. Et
donc pour empreinte à cette loi du FCPA,
la peine de prison est calculée sur le
profit réalisé par l'entreprise sur les
projets incriminés. Donc euh même s'il y
a pas de rétrocommission, ce qui était
bien sûr le cas, pas d'enrichissement
personnel, peu importe. À partir du
moment où Alstom avait déclaré qu'ils
avaient fait x million de profit sur ce
projet, pour moi ça une fourchette de 15
à 19 ans de prison si je perdais euh au
procès. Mon avocat me dit "De toute
façon,
rien que pour regarder les documents et
un million de pièces, il va falloir 3
ans avec des équipes de Forenzi
pour essayer de trouver la
substantifique moelle la nant qui vous
concerne
ça va coûter entre 5 et 10 millions de
dollars.
Et on ensuite on va prendre 12 personnes
dans la rue. On va leur expliquer une
entreprise française a fait la
corruption en Indonésie il y a il y a 10
ans euh contre une entreprise
américaine. On peut vous montrer les
statistiques mais oubliez quoi. Et donc
l'alternative c'est vous plaît des
coupables et vous plaît des coupables
sans même regarder quoi que ce soit. Et
si vous plaît des coupables, vous sortez
au bout de 6 mois.
Donc vous réfléchissez mais vous
réchissez pas trop longtemps parce qu'il
vous donnent pas trop de temps non plus.
Ils vous disent voilà c'est un deal qui
est sur la table mais le deal va pas
rester sur la table très longtemps. Donc
il faut il faut vous décider.
Et donc après euh 4 mois dans cette
présent de haute sécurité, donc en 4
mois et demi même euh en fin juillet
2013, j'ai décidé de de plaer des
coupables. Et donc là euh
votre avocat se met d'accord avec le
procureur sur un texte que vous devez
lire devant devant un juge. Et ça
commence comme ça. C'est je Bonjour, je
m'appelle Pierucci. Je suis je plaque
coupable. Je n'ai reçu aucune pression
physique et psychologique pour plaider
coupable. Euh je ne ferai pas de possè
euh au gouvernement américain, je suis
content euh des services de mon avocat
et cetera et cetera.
Donc vous lisez ce papier.
Donc après ça, je retourne en prison euh
et j'attends patiemment la fin des des 6
mois.
Alors, entre-temps, je reçois d'abord
une lettre d'Alsom qui m'est envoyé via
ma famille euh qui me demande non même
pas. Au début, il me demande de venir à
Levalois pour un entretien palable de
licenciement.
Euh alors, ils connaissent que c'est
peut-être un peu compliqué pour moi de
de venir. Donc, il me demande de mettre
mes grif par écrit pour empêcher ce ce
licenciement. Donc ma famille fait des
pieds et des mains en France pour
essayer d'arrêter ça. Mais euh notamment
ma femme de avait demandé avait obtenu
un rendez-vous avec
Patrick Ron et qu'il a annulé. Donc ma
ma famille, ils ont coupé complètement
tous les contacts avec ma famille et à
la demande du ministère de la justice.
Ce qu'il faut
non américain.
Américain.
Ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que quand
vous êtes sous enquête comme ça, vous ne
dirigez plus votre boîte quoi. C'est le
département de justice qui via l'avocat
que l'entreprise a choisi qui dirige
votre entreprise.
Ah et c'est eux qui décident si vous
allez à droite ou si vous allez à
gauche.
Et donc euh
donc je reçois cette cette lettre. On
n'arrive pas à à la bloquer bien
évidemment parce que le département de
justice américain leur a dit de me virer
vu que j'avais appelé des coupables. Et
donc un mois après, je reçois ma lettre
de licenciement et je suis licencié pour
abandon de poste. Effectivement, je suis
plus aux États je suis plus à Singapour
en train d'exercer mon job. Je suis dans
une prison de votre sécurité.
Donc là euh ça devient plus compliqué
euh parce que deux choses vont arriver
ensuite. Un euh il le procureur va dire
à mon avocat, ben les 6 mois ça tient
plus.
Alors là je comment je demande à mon
avocat mais comment ça se fait ? Je
pensais que vous aviez un accord avec le
procureur. Euh, il me dit "Oui, dans le
Connecticut, on met pas d'accord par
écrit, c'est que verbal. Mais comme on
est tous de la même famille, les
procureurs, on peut les croire sur
parole. Ça n'est jamais arrivé en 40 ans
de carrière qu'un procureur revienne sur
sa parole sur ces sujets-là." Euh je dis
"Moi, ça fait une belle gens, mais là,
il revient sur sa parole là." Euh, il
dit "Oui, je ne comprends pas ce qui se
passe." Euh, bon donc il dit "Voilà,
vous serez pas libéré." Alors, je
demande combien de temps euh je vais
rester. Dis entre 6 et 10 mois. et sans
me donner de des des des d'explications.
Et toujours au QHS,
toujours euh alors entre-temps, ils
m'ont transféré dans une partie encore
plus sécurisée de cette prison euh où là
on a même pas le droit d'aller dans une
cour de temps en temps dehors. Donc là,
c'est euh voilà, c'est une pièce où on
mange et autour des cellules où on dort.
Voilà, c'est tout. On peut pas on peut
pas prendre l'air du tout.
Et donc euh
je
deuxème événement euh il me disent ben
on arrête de payer vos avocats. Voilà
parce que vous avez PL des coupables et
donc l'entreprise ne veut plus continuer
à supporter des frais d'avocat de
quelqu'un qui a qui a PL découpable.
Alors là c'est le trou du trou parce que
vous savez pas combien de temps vous
allez rester votre avocat. Alors il peut
pas se défausser en fait. Il y a quand
même une règle aux États-Unis, c'est que
même si vous ne le payez pas, il peut
pas il peut pas ne pas vous défendre,
mais il va pas vous défendre avec la
même ardeur si vous ne le payez pas,
bien évidemment. Donc ces visites sont
devenues extrêmement rares. Euh et donc
je sais pas ce qui se passe et donc je
reste dans cette prison euh alors 6
mois, 7 mois, 8 mois, Noël passe, le
Noël en passe. Euh
toujours pas de nouvell,
toujours pas de nouvell du Korse
de personne. Le Kerson entre-temps a
délégué quelqu'un pour venir me voir,
quelqu'un de très bien d'ailleurs de de
de Boston,
un vice-consul mais le le le pauvre, il
a il a compris ce qui s'est passé dans
dans mon cas. Il a essayé d'alerter ses
ses supérieurs et euh
ses supérieurs étaient déjà au courant,
non ?
Alors ces supérieurs étaient au courant
mais il je sais pas si moi je sais pas
ce qui se passe en France à l'époque.
D'accord. Je sais pas qui comprend quoi
à l'époque. Et donc euh je sais pas si
vous souvenez, mais en février 2014,
Hollande est venu aux États-Unis.
euh visite d'état et donc à l'époque le
le vice-consul avait fait beaucoup de
choses pour essayer de faire que mon cas
soit discuté lors de lors de la visite.
Euh donc il y a beaucoup d'espoir qui
étaient bâtis autour de ça pour finir
mais tout seul parce que en fait Alstom
ne fait rien donc c'est ma famille et ce
vice-consul qui essayait qui essayant de
de bouger les choses. ma famille va voir
le quedoré par contre en France. Et là
on lui dit en dit à ma famille écoutez
monsieur madame on a 2000 prisonniers
français dans les dans les prisons. Pas
partout dans le monde. Pourquoi ? Parce
qu'on va s'intéresser plus à à monsieur
Pirochi que 1999 autres. Voilà. Et donc
il ne comprennent rien à ce qui se
passe.
Ils font semblant de pas comprendre.
Oui, ils font semblant de pas
comprendre. Euh ma famille écrit à
l'Élysée aussi. Pareil, il font
semblement de pas comprendre. Euh et
donc lors de cette visite, en fait, il y
avait beaucoup d'espoir mais il ne se
passe strictement rien.
Donc euh arrive ensuite avril 2014, donc
ça fait 1 an que je suis dans cette
prison de sécurité et là euh
je vois à la télévision parce que dans c
dans ces prisons américaines, dans cette
salle seule salle, vous avez trois trois
télévisions. Une télévision pour les
noirs, une télévision pour les
hispaniques et une télévision pour les
blancs. Et donc je vois à la télévision
que il y a cette annonce qui qui dit que
Alstom est en train de se faire racheter
par G électrique. Et donc là, moi je
connecte tout de suite les deux parce
que entre-temps, j'ai étudié tous les
cas des des entreprises qui avaient été
mises en examen par le département de
justice pour empruntinte à cette loi du
FCPA. Euh donc tous les cas des
individus, tous les cas des entreprises
et lorsque vous faites l'analyse de tous
ces cas, vous voyez vraiment une image
qui se dessine extrêmement claire que
guerre économique
de guerre économique. Voilà. Et vous
vous rendez compte que Gen Electric fait
cinq entreprises qu'il rachètent euh
parce que l'entreprise est sous enquête
du département de justice pour en
freinte à cette cette seule loi du FCPA.
Donc moi je connais je je comprends tout
de suite ce qui se passe. Euh j'appelle
mon avocat, je lui dis "Bon maintenant,
arrêtez de vous [__] de moi. Euh je
sais pourquoi je je suis là. Euh bon, il
fait semblant de pas comprendre et
cetera, mais au fond du compte, je sais
très bien qu'il a compris. Euh
en France, bah à l'époque, il y a quand
même Mondbourg qui comprend. Euh faut
lui rendre hommage quand même. C'est
c'est je pense que c'est en tout cas
l'un des seuls qui s'est exprimé euh
là-dessus parce que lorsqu'il y a eu
cette annonce de Bloomberg qui annonce
que Jenck est en train de racheter
Alstom et euh il demande à Patricon de
venir au ministère et s'en suit une
discussion assez assez chaude dans tous
les cas. Et donc euh
alors les mois entre avril et juin sont
très mouvementés en France sur le sujet.
Euh à l'époque Mbourg essaie de monter
une contreoffre avec Siemens.
Alors elle a peu de chance d'aboutir
parce que Siemens s'est déjà fait euh
euh a déjà été mise en examen et elle a
déjà payé une amende de 800 millions de
dollars pour les mêmes faits de
corruption par infligés par le
départemental de justice quelques années
avant. Donc il y a pas beaucoup de gens
extrêmement intéressés pour replonger
dans une dans une affaire où on va
racheter une boîte qui est de nouveau
sous de nouveau sous une enquête. Mais
bon, ils essayent quand même. Euh et
pour finir, les États-Unis me libèrent
la semaine où le gouvernement français
décide que c'est euh JRIC qui rachète
Alstom et pas et pas Siemens.
Donc euh mais il me libère euh sous
caution, c'est-à-dire que euh il me
demande de mettre une caution d'un
million et demi de dollars. Là, je
reviens à ce que je vous ai dit au
début. Comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
vous vous tenir ? Ils peuvent vous tenir
par l'argent.
Et donc là une caution d'un million et
demi de dollars. Moi, j'avais pas 1
million de000 de dollars à l'époque,
j'en ai toujours pas. Donc on fait les
fonds de tiroir dans la famille. Bien
sûr, on ne trouve pas cet argent et les
Américains demandent en plus que deux
Américains mettent des leurs propres
maison en caution pour me libérer. Euh
alors je sais pas si vous si vous vous
imaginez dans une situation pareille,
vous discutez avec vos amis, avec votre
famille. Est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
mettre votre maison à caution pour
quelqu'un qui accusé de corruption qui
est en prison américaine dans une autre
prison de votre sécurité ? Vous pouvez
faire le tour mais il y a pas beaucoup
de volontaires quand même. Euh
c'est qu'on voit ses vrais amis.
C'est là où on voit ses vrais amis. On
fait on on fait on fait le tri. Mais par
miracle, on arrive à trouver deux amis
américains et je redois quand même
énormément qui acceptent de mettre leur
propre maison en caution. Donc euh ils
mettent cette leur maison en caution et
je suis libéré donc euh à la mi mi-join.
Euh pendant quelques mois, je reste aux
États-Unis parce qu'il n'accepte pas que
je que je revienne en France. Euh
et finalement contre l'émission encore
de 200000 dollars en plus, ils acceptent
que je revienne en France euh en
septembre 2014. Sauf que je reviens en
France sans être jugé.
aux États-Unis, c'est un c'est un fusil
de coûp. Soit vous plaidez coupable euh
soit vous êtes jugé coupable lors d'un
procès et ensuite 3 mois après, on vous
signifie votre peine.
Moi là, ça faisait plus d'un an que
j'avais appelé des coupables mais que il
ne voulait pas me donner ma peine et ma
peine aurait dû être 6 mois vu que c'est
ce qu'ils avaient négocié avec mon avec
mon avocat. Donc euh je reviens en
septembre 2014 en France
mais le département de justice ne veut
pas ne veut pas me juger.
Alors pourquoi ils ne veulent pas me
juger ? parce que benah il souhaite pas
que une fois que je suis jugé, je peux
commencer à parler bien évidemment et
donc à révéler tout ce que j'avais
compris de de cette affaire et qui
rejoignait ce que ce que Montbourg avait
compris aussi à l'époque et
que Montbourg avait compris que c'était
un braquage à l'ancienne sur une
entreprise stratégique. Ah ben il avait
compris que il avait fait le lien entre
la procédure judiciaire aux États-Unis
et l'opération de l'opération de rachat,
ce qu'il redira plus tard lorsqu'elle eu
la commission d'enquête parlementaire et
cetera sur le sur le sujet. Euh donc euh
je reviens, je ne suis pas jugé. Alors
euh je vais m'inscrire à Pô l'emploi
parce que j'ai pas d'autres d'autres
choix. Euh difficile de trouver un
boulot quand même parce que je viens de
passer 14 mois en prison de sécurité.
Euh vous avez mon nom sur internet,
c'est facile de retrouver la référence.
Euh
je me voyais mal voir aller voir un
employeur en disant "Bon, je suis un je
suis un bon directeur, je suis un euh
faites-moi confiance, je sors de prison,
je risque d'y retourner mais je sais pas
quand et je sais pas pourquoi de temps
quoi. Mais embauchez-moi." Donc c'est
c'est pas le genre de discours qui
marche très très bien. Euh donc euh
DGSE vous fait aucune proposition ?
Non. Alors DGSE ne fait aucune
proposition. Par contre, je suis euh
je vais assez rapidement voir les
services d'intelligence économique de
Merci.
D'accord.
Euh qui euh en gros m'explique que eux
avaient compris ce qui se passait,
d'accord ? Et qu'ils avaient fait
mais ils avaient rien fait. Ils avaient
report, ils avaient fait monter ça
au-dessus et que
Macron était auudessus ou c'était
alors à l'époque il ils m'ont pas
mentionné Macron mais ils m'ont dit en
gros leur supérieur quoi. À l'époque
Macron venait de prendre ses ses
fonctions en septembre 2014. Donc
c'était c'était c'était avant Macron. et
donc qu'ils avaient fait des notes en
interne mais que en gros mentionné à
l'époque le nom du premier ministre Vals
à l'époque et que ça les intéressait pas
parce que voilà en tout cas que il y
avait pas eu de répondance sur ce sujet
et dans les notes ils avaient m'avaient
mentionné en étant comme étant l'otage
économique. Donc ils avaient très bien
compris ce ce qui ce qui se passait.
Donc euh ben voilà, vous êtes content
parce que vous dites que votre pays a
compris ce qui se passe. En tout cas,
certaines personnes ont compris ce qui
se passait mais personne n'a bougé.
Donc euh comme j'avais accumulé quand
même énormément de notes pendant ces 14
mois, pendant j'ai fait des analyses
sectorielles, j'ai fait analyse dans
tout dans tous les sens pour regarder
comment cette loi a été appliquée,
comment surtout elle s'appliquait aux
entreprises plutôt européennes
qu'américaines. Euh ben j'ai je pense
que j'ai j'ai je suis j'étais devenu
bien malgré moi un expert dans dans le
domaine. Alors j'avais fait ça pas pas
pour amuser, j'avais fait ça pour me
défendre. J'ai essayé de trouver de la
jurisprudence qui pouvait essayer de de
m'aider dans mon cas.
Donc euh j'ai fait deux choses à
l'époque. J'ai un créé une boîte de
conseil là-dessus pour alerter les
entreprises et pour faire de la la
sensibilisation auprès des des grandes
entreprises françaises et des plus
petites. Et euh j'ai travaillé avec
un avocat qui était l'ancien bâtonnier
euh Paul Berince pour essayer de faire
bouger la ligne en France sur ces
sujets-là.
La dit La dit vous est approché ou pas ?
Non. l'agence pour la diffusion de
l'information technologique.
Non non non, aucune approche de la dite
à l'époque.
Euh j'ai été donc à l'époque avec pas
mal de de personnes qui avaient compris
aussi ce qui se passait. Par exemple, on
a en
on a organisé à l'Assemblée nationale un
colloque qui s'appelait après
Alsamilour, donc pour sensibiliser les
députés à la nécessité de changer la loi
française pour protéger les entreprises
françaises. L'idée étant de dire euh
nous faisons raquetter par le
département of justice.
Les entreprises françaises payent des
amendes absolument colossales au trésors
américain pour empreintre à différentes
lois extraterritoriales américaine
toujours sous couvert de bonne moralité
hein. Tout le monde tout le monde est
contre la corruption bien sûr. Moi aussi
je suis contre la corruption. Donc en se
cachant derrière ces ces ces valeurs
morales, les États-Unis font une guerre
économique sans pitié à leur notamment à
leurs alliés principalement à leurs
alliés. Donc tout ça j'avais bien
documenté. Euh et donc on a on a réussi
à faire bouger un peu les lignes. Alors
d'autres aussi ont bougé à l'époque
hein, le MDF a commencé à bouger et
cetera parce que ça commence à faire
beaucoup euh de d'entreprises qui se
faisaient euh ponctionner
détroussé
détrussé
et donc est arrivé la loi Sapin 2
ensuite euh qui n'est pas parfaite mais
qui au moins permet de rapatrier une
partie des des cas des entreprises
françaises qui seraient sous enquête
américaine de rapatrie en France. Alors,
on va voir comment ça va se passer. Pour
l'instant, on aura pas trié un seul cas.
C'était le cas de la société générale
l'année dernière où il y a eu l'amende a
été partagée entre le trésor américain
et le trésor français à hauteur de 5050.
Euh et on va voir dans les prochains cas
notamment le cas d'erbus, comment tout
ça ça ça tout ça ça va ça va finir. Mais
l'idée étant voilà de de rapatrier en
France ces quatre ces cas d'entreprise
françaises et de les traiter auprès des
tribunaux français en espérant que euh
les États-Unis derrière appliqueront ce
qu'on appelle non bisingem. C'estàd
qu'on va pas juger deux fois pour la
même chose, chose qui n'est pas encore
gagné euh vu les précédents. Donc donc
j'ai fait ça et puis pendant plus de de
3 ans donc j'ai j'ai
continué cette euh ce travail. J'ai créé
donc c'est cette cette société de
consulting. J'ai fait beaucoup de
missions mais j'étais toujours pas jugé.
Donc j'avais toujours cette épée de
Damoclè parce que j'avais du plaid des
coupables de deux chefs d'accusation euh
qui en théorie euh
me faisait peser sur moi quand même une
peine de prison qui allait encore
jusqu'à 10 ans. Et donc euh au bout de 3
ans euh j'en ai eu marre en fait
d'attendre et je pouvais plus vivre avec
cette ép démocratie sur la tête. Et donc
j'ai décidé euh de demander à mon avocat
de forcer ce qu'on appelle le
Saintensing. Donc c'est le
donc le mon jugement final. Alors là,
mon avocat m'a dit "Bon, écoutez euh
c'est vrai maintenant ça fait 3 ans donc
on peut on peut y aller." Enfin 4 ans
après, ils m'ont fait les coupables
alors que normalement c'est que 3 mois.
On y va. Euh ça va être une formalité.
Vous vous deviez faire 6 mois, vous en
avez fait 14 en plus en présent de votre
sécurité.
Donc euh pas de souci. Donc on j'y vais
euh j'y vais sans trop de
d'appréhension.
Donc je retourne dans le CCAT et là je
vois la première pour la première fois
la juge. Alors j'ai en 5 ans et demi de
procédure, j'ai jamais vu juge. C'est
qu'une négociation entre votre avacueur
et le procureur que ce soit pour les
entreprises ou pour les particuliers. Et
donc la juge me dit "Monsieur Pierucci
euh on a regardé un peu dans nos
archives et dans le Connectic Cut, nous
n'avons trouvé aucun cas de personne euh
qui a été mis en qui a été mise en
examen pour cas de d'emprinte à cette
loi du Foreign Corpice Act. Alors c'est
une loi qui date de 1977. Là, nous
sommes en 2017. Donc, en 40 ans, les
agents du FBI n'ont jamais trouvé une
seule personne dans l'état du
Connecticut qui a enfin cette qui est
enfin cette loi. Euh l'état du
Connecticut, c'est quand même là où vous
avez le siège de Gener Electric, de
United Technology, de Sorski, de Prat
Whitney, de des grandes banques, de
grandes entreprises d'assurance et
cetera et cetera. Mais aucun cas de
corruption de pendant 40 ans de toutes
ces entreprises sur les marchés
internationaux, bien évidemment.
Et donc le premier cas, c'est un
français qui travaille pourom. Et donc
la juge me dit "Ben on va on va on va
faire un exemple." Et donc on vous
condamne à 30 mois.
Et donc euh
30 mois ça veut dire ben monsieur PI,
vous devez retourner en prison pendant à
peu près 12 mois parce que avec les
remises de peine qui sont que de 15 %
aux États-Unis.
Donc là, ça fait un peu bizarre parce
que alors ils acceptent que je retourne
en France simplement pour faire mes
bagages, dire au revoir à la famille et
revenir. Alors pourquoi je reviens ?
Parce que il les tiennent toujours ma
caution d'un million et demi de dollars
et donc de maison de mes amis. Donc
quand je reviens en France pendant cette
très courte période, je vois euh
plusieurs anciens ministres qui me
disent "Surtout n'y retourne pas." Euh
on connaît les on connaît les
Américains, c'est trop risqué. C'est
avec ce que tu sais sur l'affaire
Alstom, c'est trop risqué d'y retourner.
C'est risqué parce que vous allez vous
prendre un coup de surin en prison.
C'est
bah c'est un peu ce qu'ils me disent
quoi. C'est c'est un peu ce qu'il me
disent. Euh
si tu si tu retournes là-bas sans même
avoir parlé de de cette affaire là, il y
a un risque physique.
Bon euh c'est vrai que j'hésite beaucoup
à l'époque euh parce que le bon j'avais
les deux maisons de mes de mes amis qui
étaient en caution. Donc là je pouvais
pas les laisser tomber et ensuite après
avoir une vie de fugitif. Euh c'est
quand même quand même problématique
parce que dans ce cas-là, vous êtes
terré en France pendant toute votre vie.
Euh vous ne sortez pas de France, ça
coûte cher et cetera. Donc puis
monsieur Cron voulait pas ça.
Voilà. Et puis j'avais euh enfin j'avais
même pas 50 ans quoi. Donc euh c'est
long une vie de fugitif quand vous êtes
50 ans. Donc euh donc je décide de
retourner
et donc bah là j'achète un un ticket
d'avion
sans retour.
Euh je me fais déposer à la porte de la
prison par un taxi euh sans rien dans
les poches parce que de toute façon on
pouvait rien amener dans dans ces
prisons américaine. Euh et euh je
retourne dans une prison qui m'ont
désigné dans le dans le en Pennsylvanie.
Donc là, ce sont des prisons
euh euh c'est des prisons que pour
étranger. Euh là donc 1800 personnes
pareil dortoir de 72 personnes pour une
capacité de 49. Donc vous imaginez un
peu comment on était un peu serré comme
des sardines. Pareil, une seule pièce.
Euh mais là on pouvait on pouvait aller
dehors de manière régulière. Il y avait
un terrain de foot et cetera. Donc
c'était un peu plus un peu plus relaxe.
Donc 1800 personnes, 1000 Mexicains, 500
dominicains et après le reste de gens
qui venaient un peu partout. Euh
beaucoup de russes, beaucoup de gens des
pays de l'Est.
Bon voilà et donc vous faire votre trou
dans cette dans cette dans cette
nouvelle prison.
Euh alors dès que je je rentre dans
cette prison, je demande ce qu'on
appelle mon transfer où il y a des
accords bilatéraux entre la France et
les États-Unis et entre les États-Unis
et l'Europe de manière générale pour
transférer les prisonniers qui n'ont pas
d'attache locale. Donc là moi j'avais
pas aucune famille aux États-Unis, aucun
attachement. J'avais de des enfants en
basâage quand même en France.
Et donc avec l'ambassade de France là
qui a fait son boulot euh qui là autant
pendant la première partie
d'incarcération à part le vice-consul
qui avait fait un boulot extraordinaire.
toute l'administration française a été
aux abonnés absents complètement
à la rue
à la rue. Euh mais pendant la deuxième
période là, je reçois un certain soutien
de l'ambassade parce que mon cas était
quand même un peu un peu connu en France
quand même depuis voilà, on est on est
en 2017 et donc euh
on fait les papiers de de de demande de
transfer. Alors, j'ai coché toutes les
toutes les cases pour être transféré.
Euh j'ai fait plus de la moitié de ma
peine, pas d'attache locale et cetera et
cetera.
Et très rapidement, le ministère de la
justice américaine refuse mon
transformant.
Alors euh
bon, c'est quand même un peu
problématique. On a des accords
bilatéraux, il appliquent pas. Euh alors
pourquoi elle le refuse ? parce que un
mois après mon incarcération aux
États-Unis, vous avez une commission
d'enquête parlementaire qui est ouverte
en France sur le casadre du rachat
d'Alsom par général électrique. Et donc
il ne souhaite bien sûr que pas que je
témoigne dans cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire. Euh alors le président
est Olivier Marlex à l'époque et la
vice-présidente est Natalia Pusref de
République en marche.
Euh et eux euh décident quand même de
venir me voir dans cette prison euh pour
mauditer lors dans le cadre de cette
commission d'enquêre parlementaire.
Alors, ils le font sous couvert d'une
visite consulaire que les Américains ne
peuvent pas refuser. Donc, ils viennent
avec le consul de France dans dans la
prison juste comme excuse et le consul
de France reste là pendant 4 5 he juste
à attendre que que l'audition
se fasse.
Et euh donc je trouve quand même un peu
le temps long, mais cette deuxième
période d'incarcération est quand même
un peu plus simple parce que normalement
il y a une date de sortie que vous
connaissez. Donc quand vous connaissez
la fin de tout, ça c'est ça aide
beaucoup plus
ça donne de l'espoir. Vous savez qu'il y
a une normalement il y a une date
finale.
Donc euh
ensuite cette cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire se termine en en avril. Il
y a la visite de Macron à l'époque en
avril aussi et là on refait une demande
de transfer
et comme par hasard les Américains
l'acceptent. Donc
sauf qu'ils vont mettre tellement de
mauvaise fois
à à mettre en place transfer notamment
il me renvoie dans une autre prison de
enfin il me faire un petit un petit
voyage entre-temps il m'amène dans une
prison ensuite dans une autre prison et
je finis dans dans dans une dans la
première prison de haute sécurité dans
laquelle j'avais passé la première nuit
euh quand j'avais été arrêté en en en
2013. Donc je me retrouve à Manatan euh
pendant une quinzaine de jours. Alors à
l'étage supérieur, vous avez El
Chachapu, le patron de la drogue
mexicain euh qui euh bah qui a
l'isolement et moi, il me mettent avec
son Siicario qui avait 158 meurtres au
compteur, avec son son banquier. Euh et
donc on se retrouve là. Bon, des gens
avec qui de toute façon vous, comme avec
tous les autres, vous vous devez
partager tout. Euh à l'époque là, on se
partage des sandales pour aller à la
douche à quatre quand même parce qu'on a
rien tout dans ces prisons américaines,
tout est ce sont des prisons privées où
vous devez acheter tout quoi. Et et donc
c'est très extrêmement compliqué même
d'avoir un verre d'eau, d'avoir d'avoir
tout.
Et donc il me il me laisse là et pour
finir il me transfère en France un mois
avant la fin de ma peine.
Et donc euh
il y a lorsque j'arrive euh à Charles de
Gaul euh comme en France on fait les
choses bien euh on me un carter en
France à Ville. D'accord. pour faire la
fin pour finir ma peine et donc comme
j'avais fait euh plus de 95 % de ma
peine où c'est en France, on peut être
libéré euh au de tiers de sa peine. Donc
euh après quelques jours, je suis
finalement libéré et donc je suis libéré
euh euh fin septembre 2018, donc il y a
il y a moins d'un an.
Et euh ben dès que je suis libéré, bon
alors je je finis le le livre que
j'avais écrit. J'avais écrit plus de
2000 pages d'analyse en long, l'argent
en travers euh de de tous ces cas. Euh
j'avais écrit le livre avec un
journaliste que j'avais rencontré
pendant la la période où j'étais où
j'étais dehors, Mathieu Haron. Euh et
donc on je décide de publier très
rapidement ce livre-là pour ben pour
aller essayer d'alerter tout le monde.
Alors le choix était fait de de de faire
un livre qui s'adresse que tout le monde
peut lire en fait hein euh plutôt que de
faire un livre très technique. Euh en
fait c'est c'est c'est plutôt expliqué
quand un peu quand quand comme un polar.
Euh alors on finit juste pour
l'anecdote, on finit avec Mathieu de de
d'écrire ce ce livre. On envoie aux
éditions lates le le manuscrit le
vendredi et le samedi se fait cambrioler
chez lui et on lui pique ses
ordinateurs, son ordinateur sur lequel
il y avait le manuscrit du livre le
piège américain. Euh et on lui pique pas
on lui pique quelqu'un d'autre quoi en
fait hein. Donc à Paris au mois de
novembre.
Donc là à votre avis c'est les Français
ou les Américains qui l'ont attrapé ?
J'en sais rien. J'en sais rien. En tout
cas il y avait des gens qui voulaient
lire le livre avant qu'il ne sorte. Moi,
je mets 50 € pour que pour sur la tête
des Français.
J'avoue que je suis partagé.
Ouais,
je suis partagé.
Euh mais en tout cas, il y avait des
gens qui voulaient savoir ce qu'il y
avait décrit avant. Donc et pour finir,
le livre, on arrive quand même à à le
sortir le sortir en janvier. Alors là
euh là là c'est amusant parce que on a
l'impression que tout le monde découvre
ce qui s'est passé sur le Calstom alors
que c'est quand même qu'il y avait quand
même beaucoup de gens qui avaient tiré
la sonnette d'alarme depuis euh depuis
pas mal temps. Le Calstom le Calstom
c'est une entreprise stratégique
française qui nous fait des turbines
pour nos portesavion, nos centrales nos
centrales électriques
sur le l'hydraulique
sur tout un tas de choses sur notre
porteavion. D'ailleurs, il y a il y a
une belle turbinal stom dessus.
Et euh c'est une entreprise stratégique.
C'est une entreprise stratégique qui a
été vendu euh en partie en grande partie
aux États-Unis. Donc maintenant, les
États-Unis peuvent nous mettre une
laisse à la pâte sur nos exportations ou
nous mettre une laisse à la pâte si on
refuse de se plier à leur commandement.
C'est-à-dire ils nous fourniront plus
les pièces pour entretenir notre propre
matériel. C'est-à-dire que on avait déjà
un Charles de Gaulle avec des problèmes
d'hélice. Maintenant, si on a un
problème de turbine sur le Charles de
Gaulle, on est obligé de demander au à
Papa l'américain qui nous donne les
pièces.
Alors, vous avez tout à fait raison,
c'est on a on a vendu une entreprise
extrêmement stratégique. Euh Alstom a
fourni toutes les turbines pour toutes
nos entraînes nucléaires euh et a fourni
le turbo de réducteur pour le Charles de
Golom. Donc euh
demain, je vous donne un exemple. Si on
n'est pas d'accord sur la politique
étrangère des États-Unis, ils peuvent
très bien arrêter de nous fournir des
pièces de rechange. Et croyez-moi, le
général électrique fera ce que le
gouvernement américain lui dit. On le
voit actuellement avec Huawei lorsqu'il
disent à Google d'arrêter de de fournir
Android à Google, le lendemain ils
arrêtent. Donc là, il pouvait se passer
exactement la même chose et ça veut dire
que ils nous mettent dans le noir et 75
% de l'électricité en France est
produite par la no centrale nucléaire.
Donc c'est pas de la fiction. Euh je
vais vous donner deux précédents quand
même. Pendant la 2e du golf, lorsque
nous avons refusé de euh de suivre les
Américain en Irak, euh ils ont arrêté de
fournir des catapultes pour le fameux
Charles de Gaul. Donc notre on pouvait
plus euh catapulter nos nos avions. Donc
euh le Carl de Gaul est resté en rad.
Euh deuxème exemple euh juste après le
rachat d'Alstom par Géner électrique
pour un différent la commercial entre G
électrique et EDF, ils ont menacé
d'arrêter de fournir des pièces de
change à EDF lorsque alors qu' Alstom
n'avait jamais fait ça. Une entreprise
française ne peut pas faire ça d'arrêter
même si différent commercial. Donc là
euh c'est d'ailleurs il y a eu un bras
de fer extrêmement violent à l'époque et
il y a eu l'activation d' un protocole
de sécurité sur nos centrales parce que
ça dépassait les les protocole de
sécurité.
Ou voilà. Donc euh donc c'est pas du
tout de la politique fiction. Donc moi
je pense qu'il y a il y a quand même des
entreprises régaliennes sur lesquelles
l'État doit avoir la même mise doit doit
que l'État doit pouvoir contrôler. Et là
euh en vendant somme, on a perdu on a
perdu notre indépendance, notre
souveraineté énergétique dans un domaine
stratégique. Et donc c'est absolument
catastrophique. Donc alors je vous
rappelle quand même pour la petite
histoire que euh
cette vente s'est faite dans des
conditions extrêmement euh
tendancieuses, on va dire euh avec la
complicité
de tout
tous les organismes américains derrière
l'offre de glectrique. Alors dans mon
livre, je l'explique mais je peut-être
mentionner un cas assez emblématique.
Lorsque
Gener Electric et Sien sont au coude à
coude pour acheter Alstom. L'argument
clé avancé par le général électrique,
donc on est en juin 2014 et de dire nous
allons payer l'amende qu'alstum
paventuellement dans le cadre de la
procédure américaine
d'enf. Donc là déjà, ils font un lien
entre le rachat et euh la future amende.
À l'époque, on ne connaît pas en juin
2014 euh le montant de l'amende. Le
montant de l'amende sera connu qu'en
décembre 2014, donc soit 6 mois après.
Donc vous imaginez un un patron
d'entreprise qui signe un chèque en
blanc. En gros, euh peu importe le
montant de l'amende, général électrique
le prendra. à l'époque, on évoque des
montants qui peuvent aller jusqu'à 1
milliard 5 euh d'amende.
Donc là, il a quand même le feu verte
son conseil d'administration pour pour
Jeffel de pour pour annoncer ça
publiquement avec monsieur Cron euh pour
essayer de pousser l'offre l'offre de
génère électrique.
Euh sauf que c'est complètement interdit
de payer l'amende de quelqu'un d'autre.
Moi, j'ai été condamné à 20000 dollars
d'amende. Personne ne peut payer mon
amende.
Surtout l'entreprise ne peut pas payer
mon amende. Même chose là. Là, ne
rachète pas l'ensemble d'alstom, rachète
les trois/4 d'alstum. Donc ne peut pas
payer euh ne pas payer payer l'amende.
Ça montre aussi et ce qu'ils avront
après, c'est qu'ils étaient euh ils
avaient suivi toutes les négociations
entre le général électrique entre Alstom
et le département of de justice. Ce
qu'ils finiront pour avouer en en
février euh 2015 que ils avaient
participé à toutes à toutes ces
négociations-là. Donc vous imaginez
Altom accusé de corruption en train de
négocier avec le Departement of justice
avec assis à côté de lui son principal
concurrent qui est encore son concurrent
et qui à qui il dévoile toute sa
stratégie commerciale, tous ses
intermédiaires commerciaux et cetera.
C'est complètement ahurissant.
Donc oui, pardez-moi. Donc euh à
l'époque en juin 2014, ça fait ça fait
pencher la balance parce que Siemens ne
peut pas proposer la même chose. Siemens
avait été condamné à 800 millions de
dollars d'amende pour des faits très
similaires par le département justice
quelques années plus tôt. Donc vous
pensez bien que chez chez Siemens, ils
ont tous très peur. Il y a h personnes
de Simens qui ont été mises en examen
par le département du comme moi. Sauf
que ces huit personnes sont réfugiées
fugitifs
en Allemagne et donc dont un membre du
board. Donc vous pensez bien que Simens
ne peut pas bouger. Pour la petite
histoire, ils sont fugitifs depuis 2011
l'année dernière. Une de ces personnes a
a eu la mauvaise idée d'aller passer ses
vacances en Croatie. La police croate
l'a arrêté et l'a envoyé aux États-Unis.
D'accord. Donc il y a aucune solidarité
européenne en terme d'extradition.
Donc je reviens à mon histoire. Donc
Simons ne peut pas faire la même chose.
À l'époque lorsqu'ils avaient payé 800
millions de dollars, ils avaient
notamment demander à Henry John Pier qui
était le patron emblématique de Siemens
de de rembourser à l'entreprise 5
millions d'euros. Ce qu'il a fini par
faire pour avoir la paix. Et donc euh
avec ça, ils les gens électriques
emporte emporte emporte à somme sauf que
6 mois plus tard donc le prix est de
12,35 milliards de dollars et génér
l'amende qu'on ne connaît dont on ne
connaît pas le montant. 6 mois plus tard
lorsqu'elle l'assemblée
générale des actionnaires qui doit
approuver la vente d'Alsom général
électrique. Donc là on est on est le 19
décembre 2014.
Monsieur Cron dit dans l'assemblée
générale, ben écoutez, il y a 6 6 mois
plus tôt, on s'est trompé. Maintenant,
le département de justice refuse que ce
soit G électrique qui paye de l'amende.
Donc, c'est Alstom qui doit payer
l'amende.
Ce qu'il en reste.
Voilà, c'est Alstom qui doit payer
l'amende. Alors, euh,
chose étrange, le prix reste le même.
Donc, au lieu d'augmenter le prix du
montant de l'amende, le prix reste le
même. Elle sera ajustée pour d'autres
raisons. Donc, en fait, cette amende,
nous allons payer deux fois. Mais ce que
ce qui est intéressant de voir là, c'est
que le département de justice, alors que
ça a été dit publiquement 6 mois plus
tôt, n'avait rien n'avait pas du tout
réagi euh alors queil savait très bien
que c'était illégal. Par contre, 6 mois
plus tard, ils le font. Donc on on s'est
fait complètement euh avoir et on ça
montre bien que tout cela était euh
était extrêmement bien organisé entre le
département de justice, généraire
électrique euh et et et tout le monde et
les services américains.
Alors, il y a plusieurs euh plusieurs
choses qui se sont passées. Ensuite,
lorsque Alstom a donc a fini par PL
découpable, en fait le le PL découpable
d'Alstom a été signé le même jour que
l'assemblée générale des actionnaires
qui validait la vente général
électrique. Donc vous aviez une équipe
en France qui attendait le vote et une
équipe aux États-Unis qui attendait pour
signer. C'est quand même un hasard du
calendrier, on va dire encore une fois
c'est des bafieux. C'est une technique
de bas de faire ça.
Oui, mais c'est ça, mais c'est ça. C'est
ça. Et donc euh alors ensuite en
normalement lorsqu'une entreprise plaide
coupable aux États-Unis
euh enfin et qu'elle est condamnée à
payer une amende, elle a cet accord qui
est qui est un accord négocié entre le
procureur et l'entreprise doit être
validé par un juge. Dans tous les cas
que j'ai vu, l'accord est validé dans
les 30 jours suivant l'accord et ensuite
l'amende est payée 10 jours après la
validation du juge. On appelle ça les
juges tampons parce qu'en fait ils n'ont
pas beaucoup de de pouvoir. Il
tamponnent simplement un accord qui a
été fait entre l'entreprise et et et le
procureur. Et donc dans le casom, il se
passe quelque chose absolument
extraordinaire qui est unique.
Alomén électrique demande à ce que le
juge n'approuve pas l'accord.
Alors on dira pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne
veulent pas que quelqu soit approuvé ?
pour une bonne et simple raison, c'est
que le g électrique comprend
que il y a encore une étape à passer et
c'est l'étape de la Commission
européenne.
Et
en 2001, la Commission européenne avait
refusé le rachat donné par général
électrique et donc et ce qui a été un
drame chez Général électrique parce que
c'était la plus grosse opération de de
racha et qui a été stoppée par la
Commission européenne. Donc là chez ils
sont dit on va pas être on va pas
refaire la même erreur qu'en 2001, on va
envoyer les Français se battre à la
Commission européenne pour qu'elle somme
soit nous soit vendu. Et donc en en ne
en ne validant pas l'accord,
la juge en fait peser une épée de
Damoclas encore sur
Alstom, sur son son dirigeant et sur le
gouvernement français parce qu'en gros
comme l'accord n'est pas validé, il peut
très bien être augmenté s'il n'est pas
validé. Si la juge décide que le que le
montant est pas est pas suffisamment
élevé, le montant est 772 millions. Et
donc et là encore une fois, c'est la les
documents sont sont disponibles
publiquement. Il demande un report de
l'approbation de la juge jusqu'à ce que
la Commission européenne en fait
approuve
et ils feront ce reporte deux fois.
Et donc cas unique euh la juge
approuvera l'accord entre Altom et et le
département de justice que en novembre
2015, soit pratiquement 11 mois après
que l'accord a été signé et juste après
que la Commission européenne est
validée. Et pendant toute cette période
là, ils ont tenu le PDG, les
actionnaires, tout le monde en haleine.
Et ça a très bien marché vu que c'est le
PDG d'Alstom avec le gouvernement
français qui sont allés se battre à
Bruxelles pour que Halstom soit racheté
par une entreprise américaine. C'est
quand même ils sont quand même très très
forts. Ils sont très très forts. Et donc
une fois que et ben bien sûr pendant
toute cette période là, moi je suis en
France et je ne peux rien faire. Je ne
peux pas parler.
Euh ce qui est extrêmement frustrant
parce que je ça je tout ça je le
comprends tout de suite mais je ne peux
pas en parler. Et donc euh l'accord est
validé et ensuite Alom paye 72 millions.
Donc vous avez imaginé que le le la juge
euh est fait perdre en fait des intérêts
au au trésor américain sur une somme de
772 millions pendant un an pour euh
faciliter leur achat.
En gros, la justice américaine est est
sous la coupe du du pouvoir américain.
En fait, on met un mot justice là où il
faut parler de négociation.
Oui.
Euh parce qu'en fait euh
négociation ou extorsion ?
Alors
moi j'ai étudié tous les cas des
entreprises qui sont passés à la fauche
coding du du département de justice pour
ces faits de corruption. Euh depuis que
la loi existe en 1977, vous n'avez que
deux entreprises qui ont osé défier le
département de justice en allant jusqu'à
un procès. C'est des des petites
entreprises américaines dans les années
90 et qui ont gagné. D'ailleurs, dans
tous les autres cas, les entreprises
font un accord avec le département de
justice. La justice négocié et derrière
la juge met simplement un tampon sur
ces accords-là. Donc cette loi peut-être
faut peut-être la rappeler un petit peu.
Donc en 1977, vous avez euh Carter qui
est au pouvoir euh qui est vu comme un
présonant assez faible à l'époque mais
qui est plutôt éthique.
Et donc vous avez un gros scandale avec
Lokid qui fabrique les fameux chasseurs
F16 et cetera américain qui avait payé
des pots de vin à peu près partout tout
autour de la planète pour gagner des
contrats notamment contre les Mirages et
cetera français et notamment en Hollande
où ils avaient payé un million de
dollars au prince consort en Hollande
pour revendre les leurs fameux avions.
Et à l'époque, ça ça cra un scandale aux
États-Unis et donc le gouvernement
américain légifère et créé cette loi
américaine qui empêche les entreprises
américaines de de avant de payer des
pots de vin à des à des agents publics
étrangers.
Alors bien sûr ça met les entreprises
américaines en situation de désavantage
par rapport notamment à leurs
concurrents européens qui eux je vous
rappelle encore une fois comme en France
vont à Ber déclarer euh déclarer les
pots de vin et c'est déductible des
impôt sur les sociétés. Donc euh
cette loi en fait pendant pratiquement
25 ans n'est pas appliquée. Euh il y a
simplement quelques petits cas
d'entreprise de temps en temps qui se
font qui se font épinglés.
Mais à la fin des années 90, les
États-Unis comprennent que euh et
notamment les grandes entreprises
comprennent qu'il y a peut-être quelque
chose à en faire. Et tout cela est
concordant avec la fin de la guerre
froide. Euh à la fin de la guerre
froide, les services de renseignement
américains euh se retrouvent euh sans
et vous avez Clinton qui euh réoriente
euh tout ce beau monde, donc les 16
agences américaines sur le renseignement
économique à la fin des années 90.
Et donc euh
les Américains vont à leur faire trois
choses via notamment le directeur
juridique de génér à l'époque qui qui
pousse le gouvernement américain et le
Congrès à rendre cette loi américaine
qui est qui était poussiéreuse à la
rende extraterritoriale. C'est-à-dire
que à partir à partir du moment où vous
faites des transactions en dollar, à
partir du moment où vous envoyez des
emails qui sont stockés ou qui se
transitent via des serveurs aux
États-Unis, vous avez un point de
contact avec le territoire américain et
donc toute l'entreprise est sous sous
juridiction américaine. Ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre, c'est que les
États-Unis en fait, comme ils contrôlent
les tuyaux financiers via le système
Swift et via les dollars et les tuyaux
euh de l'internet via les GAFA et
cetera, en fait essa de d'utiliser ces
tuyaux pour amener aux États-Unis tout
euh tous t tous les cas de d'entreprises
qui enfrainent les toutes les lois
possibles imaginables et donc pour
imposer leur leur leur leur droits via
ces via ces via ces via ces tuyaux.
Donc en 1998 la loi est devient
extraterritoriale.
Deuxième chose, ils font pression sur
l'OCDE. Ils avaient essayé avant à
l'ONU, ça n'avait pas marché. Ils cette
fois-ci, ils font pression sur les pays
de l'OCDE pour que les pays de OCDE
mettent en place leur propre loi
anticorruption pour que pour empêcher
leurs propres entreprises de faire de la
corruption à l'internationale. Et donc
cette cette convention est signée aussi
fin 97 début 98. Donc c'est pour ça qu'à
partir de de 2000 en France, on a cette
nouvelle loi anticorruption qui empêche
les entreprises françaises heureusement
de de faire de de la corruption. Et 3è
étape, vous avez le Patriote Act 2001
revu en 2005 qui donne toute l'attitude
aux agences de renseignement américaine
terrorisme
sous-gouver de terrorisme pour pour
faire de l'espionnage massif des
entreprises principalement européennes.
Ce qui sera dévoilé par Snowden, je vous
rappelle en 2013. Que dit Snowden en
2013 ? que la NSA avec le support d'une
centaine d'entreprises du numérique
américaine euh espionne toutes les
entreprise notamment française. Vous
avez une section euh qui se réfère à
l'industrie française et qui dit en fait
que toutes les entreprises qui négocient
des contrats de plus de 200 millions de
dollars sont systématiquement écoutés
par la NSA. Donc ça veut dire que tous
les cadres d'Alstom, d'Airbus, de Talè,
de d'Asso et cetera euh dès qu'il voilà
sont systématiquement euh sous écoute
que leur emails sont lu et cetera et
cetera.
Donc lorsque vous avez ces ces trois
ces trois événements qui qui se mettent
en place, vous voyez qu'à partir de
2005, les États-Unis appliquent leur
leur loi, cette fameuse loi FCPA qui est
date de 77 et qui il cible à partir de
2005, ils cible leur les entreprises
européennes,
leur concurrents directs.
Leur concurrents directs, là où il y a
encore de l'industrie. D'accord. et ils
vont commencer par des euh par des
secteurs d'activité euh où il y a une
vraie concurrence. Donc ils vont
commencer par euh tout ce qui est le
pétrole, parapétrolier, euh l'énergie,
les télécom,
les télécom et cetera. Donc vous voyez
par exemple la première entreprise non
américaine qui paye une amende dans le
cadre là, c'est non, c'est Statoil. Ce
sont les Norvégiens de Statoil.
Ensuite, vous avez Total, vous avez Len
Technipp. Euh ensuite, vous avez euh
Siemens, Dodche Telecom, euh British
Aerospace. Ils vont attaquer les leurs
amis anglais.
Alors, British Aerospace, c'était un peu
cocasse parce que ils avaient accusé
British Aerospace d'avoir payé des pots
de vin en Arabie Saoudite pour un
contrat d'armement. Bon euh c'est quand
même un peu fort de café que d'aller
regarder ce que font les les Anglais
alors que c'est quand même eux qui
contrôlent tout tout pratiquement tous
les contrats d'armement en Arabie
Saoudite à l'époque. Et donc euh à
l'époque Tony Blair monte au créneau
euh et il essaie de faire stopper cette
cette
mise en examen de British Aerospace.
Alors, il arrive plus ou moins à la à la
contourner parce que pour finir British
Space euh plaidera coupable non pas
d'emprinte à cette loi FCPA, mais de ne
pas avoir déclaré au département d'État
américain les consultants qu'ils avaient
utilisé de lors de cette vente d'armes
en Arabie Saoudite parce que les à
partir du moment où vous avez un certain
pourcentage de composants américains
dans votre offre, vous devez aller
déclarer au département de l'État vos
consultants.
Donc euh donc ils ont euh
ils sont sortis quand même avec une
amende de 400 millions de dollars Bos
Space à l'époque, ce qui a fait tout de
suite réagir les anglais. Et donc bien
avant que nous nous mettions en place
notre loi Sapin 2, eux ont mis en place
le Ukra Bribery Act en 2010 qui a la
même vocation que le que la loi 52
d'essayer de protéger les entreprises
anglaises des foudres de l'oncle Sam.
Et donc euh
alors moi je me suis amusé, enfin je me
suis amusé donc j'ai eu le temps de le
faire
euh à regarder par exemple toutes les
entreprises qui avaient payé plus de 100
millions de dollars d'amende au titre de
cette seule loi américaine. Et vous vous
rendez compte que mais alors maintenant
il y a à peu près 30 entreprises qui ont
payé plus de 100 millions de dollars.
Sur ces 30 entreprises, vous avez sep
entreprises américaines, vous avez 16
entreprises européennes. D'accord ? et
les entreprises américaines ont payé à
peu près un milliard 6 de dollars alors
que les entreprises européennes ont payé
plus de 6,3 milliards de dollars au tit
de cette loi américaine. Alors à
l'époque, vous avez pendant très
longtemps, vous n'avez pas de société
russe. Là depuis 2 ans, vous avez deux
sociétés russes qui sont rentrées dans
dans ce top 30.
Pour ça que les Russes veulent sortir de
Swift. Voilà, donc c'est les Russes
commencent à commencent à réagir. Euh
vous n'aviez pas de société chinoise
mais bon commence à attaquer les Chinois
via d'autres lois extraterritoriales
comme on l'a vu avec l'affaire Huawei et
avant avec euh l'affaire ZTE pour
emprinte aux embargos décrétés par par
les par les États-Unis.
Euh alors, je me suis amusé aussi. Euh
alors ce qui est intéressant de voir
aussi, c'est que lorsqu'on fait
l'analyse un peu plus détaillée, vous
dites "Pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
quand même des entreprises américaines
sur cette liste ?" Vous vous rendez
compte que dans la plupart des cas euh
ces euh entreprises américaines ont été
condamnées parce qu'elles étaient déjà
sous enquête de pays étrangers. Je vous
donne un exemple. Euh vous avez dans
cette liste de 7 Aliberton qui était euh
l'entreprise euh dont Dick Chen était le
patron pendant très longtemps. Euh alors
Ali Burton, une de ces filiales a été en
consortium avec Technipp pour faire un
projet au Nigéria.
Euh pour gagner ce projet, ils ont payé
188 millions de dollars de pot de vin.
Euh pas une petite somme, sauf que ce
sont les Français qui ont levé le lièvre
et donc vous avez un juge français
Vanwinbeck qui était mis sur l'affaire.
Euh dès que les Américains ont vu que
les Français ont levé le lièvre sur le
paiement de de pot de vin au Nigéria par
un consortium où il y avait Techni et
euh et à Liberton Calc Ban Rout qui
était leur filial, les Américains ont
demandé à la France de dessaisir du
dossier
et à l'époque on a été suffisamment
stupide pour le faire.
Donc euh nous sommes décidés du dossier,
nous avons envoyé le dossier aux
Américains. Donc forcément, ils ont dû
traiter le cas de d'Aliver Burton, hein,
parce que là, c'était quand même un peu
un peu trop gros. Donc euh mais ce
qu'ils ont fait, c'est qu'ils ont
surtout traité le cas de Technipp et
donc ils ont mis une amende de 335
millions de dollars à Technipp pour une
affaire que nous nous leur avons donné.
C'est complètement
C'est extraordinaire.
Ah, il joue très très bien.
C'est extraordinaire. Et
il joue très très bien. Et
euh d'autres choses à raconter ? On
passe à d'autres questions ?
On viendra sur la parce que j'ai la
communauté en direct avec nous. On on
vous posera des questions sur vos
conditions de détention un peu après.
Et euh après tout ça, maintenant vous
êtes en France euh euh
je repose la question mais toujours pas
de contact avec la DGSE ?
Non, toujours pas.
toujours pas de contact avec des bois
d'intelligence économique.
Alors euh les bois d'intelligence
économique si j'ai j'ai des contacts
parce que lorsque j'ai créé ma propre
société Ikarian, nous faisons aussi la
delligence économique. Donc forcément
j'ai eu des contacts avec des gens de la
dite et avec avec d'autres entreprises
euh avec le CISC aussi euh qui est qui
normalement depuis mars 2019 est censé
coordonner l'intelligence économique en
France. Donc
bon euh alors non mais euh ce que je
vois quand même c'est qu'il y a pas mal
de de demandes en tout cas de formation
sur ces sujets-là. Euh
notamment à l'école militaire, il y a
quand même pas mal de formations qui qui
qui
se font là. Je vois beaucoup de de
demandes au niveau de la de la police,
des gendarmes, des avocats, des des des
juges, de de l'agence des
anticorruptions et cetera. Je je vois
quand même qu'il y a une prise de
conscience depuis alors c'est assez
récent, vous allez me dire, mais qu'il y
a une vraie prise de conscience sur
cette guerre économique. Alors, je pense
qu'on est beaucoup aidé par monsieur
Trump. Euh moi, j'adore, enfin je trouve
que c'est très très bien que monsieur
Trump a été élu parce qu'il nous
réveille.
Euh parce que celui qui a quand même euh
industrialisé cette guerre économique en
utilisant le droit, c'est quand même
Obama. Alors ça été créé sur Clinton,
mais celui qui a vraiment
fait payer les entreprises européennes
au maximum, on l'a vu avec l'affaire BNP
et d'autres choses, c'est c'est vraiment
sous sous Obama. Sauf que Obama comme il
était plutôt sympa, en tout cas il était
décrit comme étant quelqu'un de sympa
dans dans les médias, bon euh on a
trouvé ça normal. On a trouvé ça normal.
C'est le soft power américain.
Et donc maintenant Trump il dit en gros
il dit ce que faisait Obama, il dit tout
haut. Euh donc au moins ça nous réveille
maintenant. Euh donc on sort de notre
l'éthargie.
Alors euh monsieur Trump, je vous donne
deux exemples quand même assez assez
assez marquants. Euh
il y a un gazoduc qui est en train
d'être construit, le Nord Stream 2 entre
la Russie et euh et l'Allemagne qui
double le gazoduc existant. Monsieur
Trump dit clairement bah c'est les
entreprises qui vont participer à la
construction de ce gazoduc, nous allons
les mettre en examen pour et les
poursuivre. Donc là,
dû aux sanctions contre la Russie.
Voilà, dû aux sanctions contre la
Russie. Donc on donc là, on voit très
bien le lien encore une fois entre
l'économie et euh l'aspect euh
géopolitique et judiciaire.
Voilà. Euh un autre cas plus récent,
c'est euh l'affaire des Roy
où euh le département de justice a mis
en examen la fille du fondateur qui est
la CFO du groupe euh qui est maintenant
euh au Canada qui attend son extradition
voilà les États-Unis et qui est euh le
sujet d'un bras de fer énorme entre la
Chine et les États-Unis avec le Canada
au milieu. Et là, vous avez monsieur
Trump qui en décembre a dit clairement
bah si j'arrive à un accord commercial
entre la Chine et les États-Unis, je
ferai quelque chose pour madame Meng.
Donc c'est quand même
absolument incroyable qu'il disent ça de
manière absolument publique. Donc
maintenant ceux qui ne veulent pas voir
que le département de justice américain
est
fait payer les rçons mais surtout et et
est à la sol enfin ce n'est pas du tout
indépendant. On parle pas de de d'un
ministère indépendant. C'est l'État,
c'est l'État américain, le département
de justice. Les juges sont complètement
absents du système comme je vous l'ai
dit depuis le début. Donc euh là ça va
nous réveiller. J'espère que ça va nous
réveiller. En tous les cas, ce que je
vois c'est que ça commence à bouger en
France.
Quelles sont les mesures proactives
qu'il faut prendre ?
Alors, il y a beaucoup il y a beaucoup
de choses qui qui qui devraient être
faites. Euh déjà, ce qu'il faut
comprendre, c'est que tout cela évolue
dans le temps. Euh parce que cette loi
FCP, elle a été elle a évolué mais
entre-temps, ils ont beaucoup d'autres
lois qui s'appliquent aux entreprises
françaises. Là, je vous ai parlé que la
corruption. sur la corruption, les
entreprises françaises ont payé 2
milliards. Sur les lois d'emprint
d'embargot américain, on a payé à peu
près 12 milliards. Donc en tout, on en
est sur les depuis 2010, une entreprise
français ont payé à peu près 14
milliards de dollars au trésor américain
pour en frein aux lois américaines.
Euh la loi sur les embargots qu'il
décrète qu'il le décrète eux-même. Euh,
on l'a vu dans le cas de l'affaire de de
la BNP où ils ont eux-mêmes payé 8,9
milliards.
Donc, vous avez d'autres lois qui
arrivent tous les ans. L'année dernière
et les Américains ont voté ce qu'ils
appellent le cloud act. Alors le cloud
act pour les non initiés euh si j'essaie
de le résumer, c'est à partir du moment
où une entreprise héberge dans le cloud
ses données et que le le service
provider est une entreprise américaine,
un procureur américain peut demander à
ces services provider américains de le
transfert de toutes de toutes les
données de l'entreprise ou des
individus, peu importe où se trouvent
ces serveurs. C'est donc là en faisant
ça, il bypasse complètement l'entrée
judiciaire international. C'est une
prolongation de des accords de Vasnard ?
Non, non, même pas. Même pas. C'est euh
c'est euh c'est une prolongation de
prisme du du En gros, c'est c'est en
fait
Prisme qui est Je vous laisse expliquer.
Alors, prisme c'est le nom que de code
de du système d'espionnage mis en place
par la NSA avec ses entreprises du
numérique américaine qui a révélé
Snowdon. C'était on appelait ça le le le
projet Prisme. Donc euh avec le Cloud
Act, les États-Unis ont légalisé en fait
les spionage économique.
Et donc là vous au lieu de passer par la
coopération internationale pour par
exemple si une entreprise française a
fait enfrein des lois américaines,
normalement vous avez une demande du
ministère de la justice américain au
ministère de la justice français et vous
avez transfert ou non transfert de
données avec en France des lois de
blocage qui qui normalement sont censées
protéger les entreprises françaises pour
exporter des des des informations à des
à des à des autorités étrangères. En
faisant ça, il il
chatinte complètement ce ce processus.
Il demande directement au service
provider américain. Donc le cloud, c'est
euh en gros euh il y a trois entreprises
qui font du cloud dans dans le monde.
Les trois plus grandes, vous avez euh
Microsoft, vous avez Amazon et vous avez
Alibaba. Donc
on a essayé en France de faire un cloud
souverain, ça n'a pas marché.
Voilà. Mais si vous êtes une grande
entreprise, vous devez stocker vos
données sur sur un de ces trois gros
cloud en gros. Et donc en faisant ça,
ils peuvent ponner toutes les données
des des entreprises. Alors normalement
le garde fou euh c'est ça doit être ce
qui s'appelle serious crime. Serious
crime c'est suffisamment vague pour
englober des faits de corruption ou et
cetera. Euh et normalement, un procureur
ne peut pas
demander cela à une entreprise
américaine sans l'accord d'un juge.
Alors ce qu'il faut bien comprendre,
alors tout le monde dit c'est un garde
fou, sauf que
entreprise étrangère, il y a pas de
juge.
Sauf que moi, j'ai fait l'analyse
simplement rien que dans l'état du
Connecticut euh sur 1200 demandes de
procureur, ce qu'on appelle de warrant à
un à un juge américain, vous avez vous
avez moins de 10 cas qui été qui ont été
refusés. Donc dans 99,9 % des cas où un
procureur demande l'aval d'un juge, ça
lui est donné. Donc voilà, ce en fait il
il y a pas il y a pas du tout de de
protection. Il faut savoir que cette
loi, elle date de elle date de mars
2018. Donc euh combien de données ont
déjà été
siphonnées euh sur les entreprises
européennes depuis mars 2018 ? Alors là,
alors comment réagir ? Alors, on fait
des rapports en France,
la rapportite aigu.
Voilà, on fait de la rapport. Alors, il
faut il faut faire des rapports. Mais en
2016, il y a déjà eu un premier rapport
qui avait été fait par qui d'ailleurs a
été très bien fait par le député
Lelouche et la députée Berger sur
l'extraterit du droit américain et en
reprenant les différentes lois et en
préconisant certaines mesures. Ce
rapport a été
euh euh
laissé sans sans réelle réaction
derrière.
Ça vient ça vient de quoi le fait qu'il
y ait pas de réaction ? Ça vient du fait
que ils comprennent pas ou ça vient du
fait qu' qu'il travaille pour d'autres
personnes. Est-ce qu'il y a il y a une
forfaiture au sein des administrations
française pour protéger les intérêts
américains ?
Alors directe
oui, la question est très directe.
Est-ce qu'on a des taupes chez nous ?
Ah ben moi je je pense que il y a des
gens en tous les cas qui euh qui ne
défendent pas les intérêts de la France
et qui devraient les défendre. Ça euh
vous avez des noms ? J'ai j'ai pas de
nom mais euh il suffit de voir euh dans
le casal Som ce qui ce qui s'est passé.
Vous avez quand même eu euh je peux pas
croire que tout le monde était été naïf
euh ce euh
il y a les Français qui sont graissés la
patte sur cette transaction. Est-ce
qu'il y a eu des plaçages ? Est-ce qu'il
y a eu des pantouflages ? Est-ce qu'il y
a eu des des des pantouflages ? Il y en
a eu euh
[Musique]
Alstom et Géner électrique ont dépensé
dans ce pendant cette version de fusion
acquisition 500 millions de d'euros en
frais d'avocat, de combinés de conseil,
de cabinet de communication et cetera et
cetera. C'est une somme absolument
colossale dans un dans une autre
procédure qui était en gré hein. Donc
c'était même pas il y avait pas de
concurrence et cetera. Donc euh
d'ailleurs, il y a une plainte qui a été
déposée
euh par le député Marlex. Euh alors on
va voir ce que ça va donner en en France
he pour pacte de corruption sur en gros
ce qu'il dit c'est qu' il y a eu il y a
eu certainement des de l'argent qui a
été récupéré euh lors de la campagne
électorale du président actuel. On va
voir, on va voir. Donc, il y a une
plainte qui a été qui a été déposée.
Ensuite, vous avez une plainte qui a été
déposée par Delphine Bateau il y a 15
jours contre l'actuel patron de Gre
électrique en France qui était à
l'époque du rachat conseillé à
l'industrie de Macron lorsqu'il était
lorsqu'il était ministre de l'économie
euh et qui ensuite après la vente est
allé chez Général électrique en tant que
secrétaire général et maintenant il est
patron de de général électrique France.
Clara Guemar ? Non, elle elle elle en
est où dans cette affaire ?
Ah bah Clara Guemar, elle elle a fait la
vente et ensuite elle est elle est
partie avec un gros chèc comme comme
beaucoup. Donc ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que son
mari fait quoi dans la boucle ? Euh
alors, je sais plus, je sais pas c'est
quelles sont ses fonctions maintenant
euh à l'époque, mais euh vous avez eu
euh la même chose euh avec euh monsieur
PCres qui était qui est devenu euh
maintenant euh qui a un poste
extrêmement important à l'intérieur à
l'intérieur de gens électrique et qui
est la seule personne clé euh que les
Américains n'ont pas viré euh parce que
tout tout le management d'alsumé
été en fait remercié après
l'acquisition. Donc vous avez eu euh en
50 même 50 députés qui ont demandé une
commission d'enquête parlementaire. Euh
donc la plupart des des députés de
droite
euh mais euh à l'époque les républicains
n'ont pas euh utilisé ce qu'on appelle
le droit de tirage. Vous savez que
lorsque vous avez un un groupe
parlementaire, vous pouvez exiger une
enquête parlementaire sur un sujet
lorsque vous dans une période de données
et les républicains ne l'ont pas fait
parce qu'il y avait pas de consensus à
l'intérieur des républicains pour faire
demande faire cette demande d'enquête
parlementaire à l'époque en 2014 qui
aurait peut-être pu faire quelque chose
à l'époque parce que la Commission
européenne n'avait pas encore approuvé
euh le donc mais ça ça a été euh sa
beauté à l'intérieur et donc il y a
d'autres personnes qui sont beaucoup
plus avisé que moi qu'il faudrait que
vous interrogiez sur ces sur ces
sujets-là. Euh oh ben des des gens comme
comme
Mi comme le député Miard, comme le
député Fasquel et cetera qui à l'époque
avait signé ses ses cette demande
d'enquête parlementaire et qui n'avait
pas réussi à convaincre les Républicains
de de faire de faire cette cette demande
de commission d'enquête parlementaire.
Alors euh et à gauche là, il y a
personne qui s'est enfin il y a très peu
de personnes qui sont sont joints à à ça
aussi. Euh ce qui est quand même
ahurissant quand quand on pense à ça
quand même que ce que ce soit un euh un
gouvernement de gauche qui est vendu euh
Alom Gén électrique. C'est quand même
C'est c'était pour protéger Cron ou pas
? Moi, je pense que Cron sé protégé
lui-même. Euh,
vous l'avez revu depuis que vous êtes
sorti ? Non, je je ne l'ai pas revu,
mais moi j'ai demandé euh plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs, il était entendu pendant
dans la commission en qute parlementaire
euh et donc il est très mal à l'aise
lorsqu'on lui pose des questions sur ce
que lui-même a signé avec le département
de justice et et en gros, il b en
touche, il dit que il ne peut pas dire
ce qu'il a signé lui-même avec le
département de justice. On faut quand
même le faire que dans une commission
d'enquête parlementaire en France
lorsque vous avez un patron du du CAC 40
qui est témoigne sous serment, il ne
puisse pas dire des choses parce qu'il a
signé des accords de confidentialité
avec le ministère de la justice
américain sur un sujet aussi stratégique
et personne ne mouff personne ne bouge.
C'est c'est hallucinant. Là là on va
parler un peu plus ouvertement. C'est
c'est c'est l'hallucination totale.
Vous avez servi d'otage.
Euh il y a un fleuron de l'industrie
française qui s'est fait liquider par
des des manières de mafieux.
On se retrouve maintenant notre
industrie, notre défense, nos rapports
avec les autres de puissance. On se
retrouve avec un boulet au pied, une
laisse à la gorge et dès qu'on bouge, on
prend un coup de collier électrique.
On on a rangé la France en terme de
vassale.
L'Europe marchand en canard en face des
États-Unis euh et les services français
euh regarde passer les mouches.
Oui, mais bon, faut jouer la deuxième
mi-temps. Moi, c'est ce que
si vous voulez,
quand est-ce qu'on se venge
? Moi je suis pas dans la vengeance
encore.
Non, je suis pas dans la vengeance parce
que je pense que les Américains jouent
très bien et nous on a mal joué.
D'accord.
Qu'est-ce qu'on aurait dû faire
maintenant ? Non non mais ce qu'on
aurait dû faire c'est trop tard.
Maintenant ce qui qu'allons-nous faire
maintenant ? C'est ça qui est important.
Vengeance.
Et je pense que
euh alors on peut essayer d'aller
retrouver les coupables et cetera et ce
moi ça m'intéresse pas. Je trouve que
euh si nous faisons ça, si nous
continuons à nous bagarrer les faudrait
mettre Cron, faudrait accuser Cron de
ça, faudrait accuser Macron ceci cela et
cetera et cetera. Pour l'accuser quoi ?
Ça
ça n'avancera rien. Ça n'avancera rien.
Je pense que là ce qui est important
pour le pays, c'est de regarder devant
comment jouer la deuxème mi-temps. La
deuxème mi-temps, il y a plusieurs
choses à faire. La deuxème mi-temps,
c'est un de récupérer ce qui est le plus
stratégique pour nous. Et ce qui est le
plus stratégique pour nous, c'est la
partie nucléaire d'Alston.
général électrique et dans uneation
financière catastrophique
pas à cause du rachat d'alstom à cause
de quelque chose qui s'est passé en 2008
qui s'appelait la case la crise des
subprime Gener Electric était avant tout
une grande banque qui s'appelait G
Capital à l'époque et qui était jusqu'au
coup dans l'affaire des subcripes. Le
gouvernement américain à l'époque a
injecté 139 milliards de dollars dans G
Capital pour sauver de général
électrique. pas rien 139 milliards de
dollars dans lorsqu'on a eu cette
opération de de d'achat par gén
électrique d'alstom je vous rappelle que
il y a certaines personnes qui ont dit
on n'est pas le Vénus, on va pas on va
pas on va pas faire de l'ingérance voilà
on va pas faire de l'ingérance
Macron qui a dit ça
voilà on va pas faire de l'ingérence
dans une une rachat d'une entreprise
privée par une autre entreprise privée
les Américains défendent leur entreprise
privée sont les plus interventionnistes
au monde d'accord pour défendre leur
propre industrie et essayer de racheter
une industrie
une entreprise stratégique aux
États-Unis. Vous allez voir qu'il y a il
y a un comité qui a été mis en place
depuis les années 80 et qui regarde ça
de manière très très paix et qui bloque
tous les investissementsindustrie
stratégique. Sauf qu'en France bon
Montbourg l'a mis en place, on faut
espérer que ça suite à l'affaire somme
elle a pas été utilisée. Donc pour finir
on il faut maintenant se mettre en ordre
de bataille pour racheter cette partie
là. Donc général électrique est dans une
situation catastrophique. Ils ont 115
milliards de dettes, 65 milliards de
cash et zéro de free cash flow. Donc ils
sont devant un mur de dette. Ils sont en
train de vendre tout ce qu'ils peuvent
vendre. Ils ont vendu une GI médicale,
ils ont vendu ils sont en train de
vendre leur participation dans Baker et
cetera et cetera. Et nous savons qu'ils
vont revendre une partie de ce qu'ils
ont acheté à Alstom dont la partie ce
qu'on appelle la partie vapeur donc
charbon et nucléaire. Donc lorsque il y
a eu cette opération d'achat à l'époque,
trois Jenture avaient été créées. Donc
une J Venture qui était à 80 % génom
et une action préférentielle de l'État
français.
Au départ c'était 5050 non ?
Ouais mais c'est c'est devenu vite 80.
Les 20 % d'ailleurs ont été revendus à
Gen électrique en en octobre de l'année
dernière. Donc c'est 100 % de génè
électrique et une par une une action de
l'État français, une Golden Share qui
lui permet à l'État français d'avoir un
certain nombre de prérogatives, un droit
de regard sur plusieurs sujets,
notamment en cas de en cas de revente.
Et donc
moi ce que ce que j'ai proposé c'est de
racheter cette partie là de faire un
tour de table et de de
ça c'est c'est c'est ce sont pas des
sommes ça fait à peu près 800 millions
de chiffres d'affaires. Ça vaut
peut-être entre ça vaut moins de 800
millions en tous les cas ça vaut entre
peut-être entre de 600 millions. C'est
c'est c'est
pas c'est pas un problème de d'argent,
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
profitable déjà parce que on fait la
maintenance de toutes les centrales
nucléaires françaises. Euh c'est la
capacité de faire les turbines neuves
derrière les nouvelles centrales
nucléaires que nous vendons quand même
encore à l'export. F un gros projet en
Angleterre avec Inkle Point. Ces
turbines sont les meilleures au monde et
de très loin parce qu'on est encore les
seuls à avoir fait à avoir eu une
industrie nucléaire. À tel point que
lorsque les Russes vendent des réacteurs
des centrales nucléaires, ils mettent
nos turbines derrière leur réacteur
nucléaire. Donc on a nous avons une John
Venture qui fait partie de cette de
cette entité nucléaire d'Alsom avec
Rosatome avec les Russes pour construire
les turbines pour ces pour ces projetsl.
Donc là, il y a un vrai projet. Il y a
un vrai projet et euh et j'espère bien
qu' que que ça va aboutir. Ça nous
permettrait au moins de recouvrir notre
souveraineté dans un dans un secteur
stratégique et de ne plus dépendre euh
des euh des aléas euh en tous les cas
euh des humeurs de Trump sur ce sur ce
ce sujet-là.
S'ils vendent pas,
mais ils vendent, ils vont vendre. S'ils
vendent pas, est-ce que ça pourrait dire
que les États-Unis c'est une stratégie
qui est beaucoup plus perforante,
profonde de mis sous tutel de la France
? Mais ça
c'est date pas d'hier. Euh ça fait très
longtemps que nous avons perdu quand
même beaucoup d'industrie extrêmement
stratégique. Je vous rappelle quand même
que Alstom c'est c'est ça faisait partie
d'un grand groupe qui s'appelait
compagnie générale d'électricité Alcatel
Alstom qui était un conglomérat qui
pouvait rivaliser avec Siemens d'un côté
avec général électrique de l'autre dans
lequel il y avait les chantiers de
l'Atlantique dans lequel il y avait
Alcatel dans lequel il y avait Alstom et
cetera et que tout ça en 15 ans ça a été
ça a complètement disparu. Ce qu'il
reste de de tout ce qu'on c'est la
partie transport d'Alston point bar.
Nous avons donc nous
on s'est fait vendre à la découpe.
On s'est fait vendre à la découpe mais
d'autres industries
sont partis de la même façon technique
s'est fait racheter. Vous il y en a
beaucoup on peut faire on peut faire la
liste est très très longue. Donc on
c'est plutôt dans une stratégie de de
reconquête actuellement plutôt que de
défense. Moi, j'ai très très bien qu'on
veuille faire des start-ups, qu'on fait
des licornes et cetera, mais avant de
faire des licornes, faut peut-être déjà
défendre les entreprises qui sont déjà
des licornes, qui sont des licornes
depuis 50 ans et dans des dans des dans
des sujets extrêmement avec des des
produits extrêmement matures et mais
extrêmement pointus. les turbines
nucléaires Arabel Dalsom, c'est le NEC
plus ultra. C'est 3000 emplois en France
qui sont extrêmement spécialisés et sur
lesquels nous sommes les meilleurs. Donc
ce qu'il faut, c'est une volonté
politique de réindustrialiser la France
dans des secteurs clés et de récupérer
par secteur stratégique les éléments
clés. Et donc moi faut com enfin
peut-être pas commencer par là mais en
tout cas il faut s'attaquer euh au
nucléaire, il faut s'attaquer au cloud
souverain, il faut s'attaquer à à à tous
ces chantiers. Pour l'instant ce que je
vois, c'est que depuis de très
nombreuses années, nous av même plus de
ministère de de l'industrie en France.
Euh
qui se soucie de ça ? Alors, on parle
beaucoup hein, il y a beaucoup de
communications maintenant sur
réindustrialisation de la France. Mais
euh moi lorsque je suis allé proposer ce
ce projet de rachat à Beril, j'ai dit de
manière très claire, regardez, on est
toujours surpris. On est surpris que
Fort une usine. On est surpris que le
repur d'Ascoval euh soit euh un canard
boîteur. On est surpris que euh J
électrique achète Alstom. On est surpris
que le gouvernement hollandais prenne
une participation dans la France KLM et
on crie à chaque fois au scandale et
cetera. Pour une fois, soyons proactif,
on sait que électrique et
catastrophique. On sait que ça va être
en vente. On a une Golden Chair dedans.
On peut on peut bâtir une offre
extrêmement sérieuse. Et reprenons ce
qui nous est d.
Pourquoi on le fait pas depuis des
années ? Il y avait Alain Juillet qui
avait été mis à la tête de la DGSE pour
faire pour former la France à la guerre
économique. Ça a pas plu. Pourquoi on le
fait pas ? C'est parce qu'on est vérôé
de l'intérieur par des intérêts de
puissance extérieure.
Bah je crois que il y a il y a une
explication donc c'est des [__] de
crétins.
Alors non mais je pense que c'est pas il
y a pas que la France. Je pense que en
France je pense qu'on on doit être
encore les seuls à avoir pour ce genre
de discours d'essayer de de récupérer
des nos billes. Euh si vous faites le
tour de l'Europe c'est bien pire. Euh
moi, je suis allé en Allemagne il y a
pas très longtemps pour faire une
conférence sur le sur ce sujet-là. Euh
les les Allemands pourtant qui ont été
sanctionnés, Siemens, Dodge Telecom,
Billfinger et cetera qui ont payé un
lourd tribut aussi au ces lois
extraterrelles américaines, on le voit
avec l'affaire Volkswagen aussi et
cetera, mais euh ils n'en sont pas dans
dans une dans un état d'esprit de comme
nous nous pouvons l'être, d'essayer de
de de reconquérir. Euh les États-Unis
sont extrêmement forts pour diviser
l'Europe.
D'autant plus que là maintenant que
Trump a mis sur la table qui voulait des
accords bilatéraux, donc lorsqu'on est
le gros et qu'on un accord bilatéral
avec un petit, forcément on va toujours
gagner. Donc vous voyez, il y a aucune
solidarité européenne sur ces sujets là.
Ce qui me désespère un petit peu, c'est
que il y a 25 ans, lorsque les
États-Unis ont attaqué les entreprises
européennes pour cartel,
euh à l'époque, les Européens avaient su
réagir, avaient mis des amendes aussi
aux entreprises américaines et depuis
chacun lève son achatal de son côté.
Euh au point que maintenant euh
tout ce qui est droit à la concurrence,
l'Europe est plutôt vu comme le leader
làdedans avec madame Ashteer qui fait un
peu la pluie le beau temps là-dessus et
que d'un point de vue mondial, on est vu
comme étant les leaders sur ce sujet-là.
Sur la corruption, on est incapable de
faire la même chose 25 ans après. On est
incapable d'avoir une coordination
européenne. Pourquoi ? Parce que le la
corruption c'est du pénal déjà. Euh et
donc c'est c'est du ressort de chaque
état.
Mais surtout parce qu'il y a pas de
volonté politique derrière. C'est parce
qu'il y a
ils sont tous
Oui, parce que euh lorsqu'on on on
montre de manière très claire que la loi
est utilisé comme arme de guerre
économique pour déstabiliser les grandes
entreprises européennes, bon, ça touche
qui ? Ça touche quand même quelques
grands pays qui ont encore de
l'industrie. D'accord. Bon, ça touche la
France, l'Angleterre, l'Italie,
l'Allemagne, la Suède,
la Norvège, mais euh si vous êtes les
pays baltes et cetera, euh ça vous
touche pas. Euh ensuite, si vous êtes
proche de l'ogre russe entre guillemets,
euh la Pologne, la Roumanie et cetera,
vous n'z vous n'alz pas avoir
la même réaction que que la que la
France. Donc c'est extrêmement dur de
trouver un consensus européen. Même avec
l'Allemagne, on narrive pas à trouver un
consensus européen là-dessus parce que
l'Allemagne regarde l'exportation de de
ses voitures aux États-Unis. Donc dès
que Trump dit "On va augmenter les taxes
sur l'importation des voitures et
cetera,
on ne réagit pas. Donc en estant quand
même assez isolé en France sur ces
sujets-là. Alors, on a fait un nouveau
rapport qui est le rapport Govin
qui vient d'être publié il y a un mois
auquel j'ai participé parce qu'on
m'avait interviewé plusieurs fois de
pour pour ce rapport qui préconise des
choses fortes. Euh
par exemple sur le Cloud Act, il il
préconise euh
de ponctionner 4 % du chiff d'affaires
des entreprises des GAFA qui
transféreraient des des des informations
à des procureurs américains. OK. Et les
4 % ils vont aller chercher grand.
Ah ah bah voilà. Non mais alors
ouais c'est un peu Cédrico. Voilà
Cédrico qui nous dit voilà si les garf
ils vont pas enlever les messages de
haine on va leur prendre 4 %.
Voilà
vous avez vu la tête de Cédrico. Est-ce
qu'il a une tête ? Il a une tête aller
chercher 4 % avec les dents
non mais vraiment
sur le papier c'est beau. D'accord.
De toute façon les États-Unis ne
comprennent que le rapport de force.
C'est ça.
Mais est-ce que vous avez vu je je veux
pas parler vulgairement. Est-ce que vous
avez vu l'état de décitude de notre
élite en face ? On a tous l'impression
quand il marche, ils laissent des traces
par terre tellement qu'ils font de
l'huile. Vous avez pas vu ça ? On les
voit marcher dans les couloirs, hein.
Le problème, c'est ça. Le problème c'est
qu'il faut une vraie volonté et que pour
l'instant on on applique rien. On
n'applique pas les propres lois que nous
avons. Regardez, je vous don prendre un
exemple lors de l'affaire snow, d'accord
? sans entreprise sans sans non mais
même sans parler de ça sans entreprises
américaines qui ont exponé des
entreprises françaises. Vous avez vu une
seule plainte ?
Attends, on a vu on a vu Cédrico qui
s'agitait dans son pays diluve.
Voilà. Il y a il y a eu zéro.
Est-ce que vous avez vu est-ce que vous
avez vu des diplomates se faire expulser
à grand coup de pied dans le cul ?
Ah ben Pascois avait fait ça à l'époque.
Avec Lodon ?
Non non Pasqua avait ça. Le dernier qui
a expulsé des des diplomates américains
en France c'est Pasquois qui avait qui
avait mis qui av mis une vingtaine dans
l'avion pour espionnage. Mais depuis
depuis il se pass rien passé. Depuis le
discours de l'ONU de de Villepin, il
s'est on s'est plus opposé au aux
États-Unis. Donc franch on a été
vassalisé, on est complètement vassalisé
comme le reste de l'Europe actuellement.
Et donc avec la guerre, ce qui se passe
avec la Chine là, c'est soit on réagit
et pour réagir fauter des des des la
manière forte parce que de toute façon,
il y a que comme ça qu' nous pourrons
nous faire respecter ou soit on va être
complètement vassisé. Demain, les
Chinois vont faire exactement comme les
Américains parce qu'ils vont pas être
bête là. Là, ils ont appris avec
l'affaire Z, avec l'affaire Huawei,
comment ça se passait et comment le
droit peut être instrumentalisé.
Ils vont l'améliorer.
Ils vont l'améliorer bien sûr, comme les
Anglais ont déjà amélioré ce qu'avaient
fait les Américains, ils vont
l'améliorer. Demain, on va se retrouver
avec le droit chinois qui va s'appliquer
parce que via les routes de la soie ou
et cetera, ils vont imposer leurs droits
tout au long de de ces routes là. Ou
comme les anglais l'ont fait, les
anglais ce qu'ils ont dit.
À partir du moment où vous avez une
filiale en Angleterre, tout votre groupe
est sous loi anglaise.
Donc vous imaginez demain les Chinois
faire un copiercollé de la loi anglaise.
À partir du moment où vous avez une
filiale en Chine, tout le groupe est
sous lou chinoise.
Donc là là c'est fini,
c'est magnifique.
Mais oui mais oui mais ils sont très
forts. Donc on va se retrouver avec
les directeurs juridiques. Je peux dire
dans les grands groupes, ils vont avoir
du boulot. Ils vont avoir du boulot
parce qu'ils vont même pas savoir quelle
loi euh
leur transaction. Faut faut voter quoi
maintenant ? Alors ça prochaines
élections
ça je ne sais pas encore. Franchement
j'ai fait un peu le tour et je vois je
vois pas beaucoup qui qui votent. Ce qui
non ce qui est amusant, c'est que j'ai
quand même eu beaucoup de contact avec
beaucoup de de beaucoup de parties euh
parce que et vous quand même vous avez
cette cette frange. Non non, vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui pensent ça, qui
pensent la même chose euh qui pensent
qu'il faut regagner notre souveraineté
économique, retrouver notre souventé
industrielle dans des domaines clés
qu'il faut réagir vis-à-vis des
Américains et cetera et full sinking.
Non. Oui, mais ce qui est intéressant de
voir, c'est que de l'extrême à l'extrême
l'extrême droite à l'extrême gauche en
passant par le centre, les écolos et
cetera, vous avez quand même
une partie de de cette population qui
qui qui sont unis sur ces sujetsl est-ce
que cette cette partie des annonces
Non, non, mais je vous parle pas de de
de je parle pas des annonces des partis
politiques, je vous parle de personnes
de de de vous avez quand même beaucoup
de gens qui qui sont offusqués de en
fait de du fait que on soit complètement
basalisé par les par les par les
États-Unis et donc qui veulent réussir
pour l'instant. Mais le problème c'est
que personne n'incarne vraiment ça dans
un parti politique tous les deux.
Euh personne n'incarde ça. Personne
n'incarte ça pour l'instant et tout le
monde fait des compromis parce que voilà
même si on est d'accord ben on peut pas
le dire officiellement parce que la
position du parti c'est autre chose et
cetera et cetera. Donc c'est extrêmement
compliqué. Mais demain on va se
retrouver complètement pris en sandwich.
Et donc euh qu'allons-nous faire ? On va
avoir simplement être
pris en sandwich, soit appliquer, soit
se ranger du côté des Américains, se
ranger du côté des Chinois. Pour
l'instant, on va se ranger du côté des
Américains et on va
se ranger se ranger du côté des Russes,
c'est intéressant ou pas ?
Bah je pense que c'est très intéressant.
Je pense que si on veut exister, il on
ne peut pas exister en Europe sans un
accord avec les Russes. Et je pense que
plutôt que faire du rush bing comme on
le fait depuis dans les médias depuis
depuis des années, on devrait se poser
la question de de plutôt faire un accord
parce que on ne peut on ne peut vivre et
avoir un vrai poids qu'en étant ensemble
avec les Russes. le monde va être
bipolaire et si on veut qu'il soit
tripolaire,
il faut il faut un accord. Sinon, les
Russes vont continuer à travailler un
peu avec les avec les Chinois. Et nous,
on va se retrouver avec qui ? On va se
retrouver
Vous connaissez les Russes ?
Je connais un peu les Russes. Ouais.
Ils toujours leurs paroles. Vous savez
pas comment il va prendre.
Ça je l'ai Ça je l'ai constaté en
prison, je peux vous dire. Ah,
dites-moi.
Ah, ça, je peux les contacter parce que
c'est vrai que les Russes en prison
respectent leurs paroles et euh, ils
sont très respectés d'ailleurs pour ça.
Euh on sait qu'ils vont pas vous faire
un enfant dans le dos et dans les
prisons, croyez-moi, c'est important de
savoir qui sont les personnes qui vont
pas vous faire d'enfant dans le dos.
Ah, le russe respecte toujours sa
parole. Toujours. Quoi qu'il arrive,
même s'il est obligé de se couper les
deux couilles, il respecte sa parole.
Mais là, non, mais vous vous avez tout à
fait raison. Il il faut il faut
réengager un dialogue avec les Russes
et créer une Europe avec avec eux. Mais
pour s'opposer au droits américains,
pour l'instant en Europe, nous n'avons
pas nous n'avons pas d'alliés. Les les
Allemands qui devraient être nos alliés
ne réagissent pas. Les Anglais pour
d'autres raisons ne réagissent pas. Euh
les et ensuite les grottes les grandes
les grands pays à la limite, il y a que
les Italiens qui réagissaient mais qui
maintenant ont un peu plus de mal à
réagir. Euh et donc
économie c'est tout ce qui leur reste
hein.
Ouais mais ils ont encore beaucoup de
belles technologies euh quand même en en
Italie. Ils ont quand même encore une
vraie industrie en Italie, mais euh les
autres pays ne vont pas réagir. Euh la
Pologne
bah par peur ou par lorsque vous êtes la
Pologne et cetera, vous là, ils viennent
de signer un accord pour acheter du LNG
américain. Donc bah voilà. Donc
forcément ça risque, on risque pas
d'avoir d'alliés de ce côté-là. On
risque pas d'avoir d'alliés du côté des
pays baltes. Donc pensez qu'on va avoir
un consensus à 28 pour s'opposer au
droit américain, c'est complètement
utopique. Donc ce qu'il faudrait, c'est
déjà nous réagir parce que déjà faut
commencer par soi-même. Avant de d'aller
chercher des alliés à l'étranger, il
faut déjà euh
un créer des lois, deux les faire
respecter et trois créer des exemples.
Euh lorsqu'on a essayé de me faire de me
transférer en France
euh
donc lors de ma 2è incarcération, comme
le département de justice avait refusé
que je sois transféré, l'ambassade avait
avait une bonne idée dit "On va faire
pendant comme pendant la guerre froide,
on va faire un transfert de prisonniers,
d'accord ? On va regarder les Américains
qu'on a en prison en France et on va
voir qui on va transférer pour vous.
60 français dans la prison américaine.
Combien de d'Américains dans la prison
française ? Zéro.
Donc le transfert était vite fait.
D'accord. Il y avait personne à
transférer.
Donc tant qu'il y a pas de de rapport de
force créé, ils vont continuer à jouer.
Il ponctionne nos entreprises
françaises. 14 milliards de dollars
depuis 2010. Il nous espionne, on ne
réagit pas. Il y a aucun procès contre
les contre les contre les GAFA qui nous
espionnent. Euh alors qu'ils ont pris
dans la main dans le sac.
On fait des
nos présidents.
Il que nos présidents, on ne réagit pas.
Euh il pigent notre industrie, on ne
réagit pas. Euh là, on fait des beaux
rapports, on les il y a il y a aucune
loi qui est derrière pour les pour les
appliquer. Ça
ça prouve bien qu'il y a des gars de il
y a des gars de chez eux chez nous.
Ah bah oui,
c'est pas possible. Bah oui, bah bien
sûr. Bah les Young Leaders et cetera,
tout tout ça. Euh bien évidemment euh
juste pour l'anecdote,
Montbourg a fait voter une loi,
d'accord, pour euh interdire les enfin
pour essayer de contrôler les
investissements. É young leader.
Oui, mais bon, les gens ont le droit de
changer aussi. Euh euh
il il s'est quand même battu lui. Faut
lui faut lui faut lui reconnaître. S'il
y en a un qui s'est battu, c'est quand
même lui.
Il a très envie d'être président.
Peu importe, il s il s'est battu, il
continue à se battre. Au moins, il l'a
dit. Euh euh il a quand même créé cette
loi pour contrôler les investissements
étrangers dans les dans les secteurs
stratégiques. Euh donc il a fait ça en
mai 2014 au moment de de la négociation
avec Alstom. Au lieu de l'appliquer à
Alstom, qu'avons-nous fait ? On l'a
appliqué à qui ? Vous vous pensez ? À
10h parce qu'on voulait pas que 10h soit
acheté par des congais.
Moi, je veux bien mais euh j'ai rien
contre la vidéo en ligne, d'accord ? Euh
mais l'appliquer à 10h plutôt que de
l'appliquer aux turbines qui fournissent
notre électricité,
je pense que il y a un manque de vision
complètement complètement.
Il y a un manque de vision complet. Donc
voilà. Donc je pense que au niveau
français, il faut essayer actuellement
arrêter l'utopie européenne en pensant
que ça que
il y aura un consensus.
commencer par nous-même, commencer à
faire
bon c'est pas compliqué de trouver des
entreprises américaines qui ont fin des
lois françaises he commen donc on
commencé à peut-être mettre en tôle
quelques quelques Américains qui ont
enfin des lois françaises, faire payer
des vrais amendes aux entreprises
américaines, créer un certain rapport de
force mais surtout s'aler avec des pays
qui sont dans la même situation que
nous. les pays qui sont la même
situation que nous actuellement euh hors
Europe, vous avez bien sûr la Chine,
mais vous avez le Brésil par exemple qui
qui ont payé aussi un très très lourd
tribut à ces lois extraterrori
américaines et qui continue d'en payer
l'Argentine aussi un petit peu
Ambrè vient d'être acheté par Boeing
juste après comme par hasard après avoir
aussi été mise en examen pour en
cette loi FCP donc un an après ils sont
rachetés par par Boeing. Bizarre, hein ?
Donc vous pouvez
voir de manière très très claire comment
ces ces billes sont sont jouées et pour
l'instant il jouent très très bien. Il y
a pas il y a pas de réaction pour
l'instant. Il y a pas de réaction. Alors
la seule réaction ce sont les Chinois.
Il faut être clair là au moins sur
l'affaire Ruawe ils sont montés au
créneau. Bon alors ils montent ils sont
montés au créneau avec leurs moyens qui
sont autres que les nôtres.
Mais euh c'est les seuls qui sont
capables de de de de d'établir un
rapport de force. avec avec les
États-Unis à ce niveau-là. Euh ce qui
est un peu dommage.
On va passer à quelques questions
d'internet. Euh beaucoup de questions
concernant vos conditions
d'incarcération.
Euh vous avez rencontré des personnages
atypiques sur place.
Avant l'interview, on a discuté un petit
peu. Vous avez rencontré des hackurs.
Ouais. Ouais. G.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire des
hackurs en prison ?
Ah, les hackurs en prison, c'est euh
alors effectivement
déjà pourquoi pourquoi il était en
prison ? J'ai rencontré un hackur. Lui,
il était en prison parce que il avait
une dent contre l'église de chantologie.
Un
beau gars.
Voilà. Et donc ce qu'il avait fait, il
avait haqué les comptes en banque de
l'église de la scientologie. Il avait
transféré de l'argent à des œuvres
caritatives. Donc il a fait une première
fois de la tole pour ça. Et ensuite euh
quand il était de nouveau libéré, il a
de nouveau hacké euh cette fois-ci
le serveur du FBI. il a fait des des
faux mandats d'arrêt contre les patrons
de l'église de la donc vous avez voilà
toute toute tout des dizaines dizaines
de policiers qui sont arrivés au siège
de lagie à Miami sur sur des fausses
alertes.
C'est du swatting dans une autre
dimension.
Ouais. Bon voilà. Mais bon, je pense que
je sais pas pourquoi
d'autres hackurs des hackurs russes.
Ouais, pas mal de hackeurs russes. Pas
mal de de hackurs russes alors qui était
qui était là qui qui avait eu la
mauvaise idée de de faire des bureaux
enfin mauvaise idée de de s'installer en
Estonie et qui avait été complètement
qui avait été euh
extradé depuis l'onie.
Extradé. Il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
gens extradés euh d'un peu près partout,
hein.
Leur russe respecte sa parole, hein.
En tout cas, en prison, euh c'était très
bien d'être avec les Russes. Euh
on on a un petit fin de club à
Saint-Pétersbourg et ils ont toujours
respecté leurs paroles. Ouais, mais faut
faut dire moi là dans la deuxième prison
où j'étais, il y avait une quinzaine de
russes, j'étais le seul français et donc
dans les ce qu'on appelle les ce qu'il
appellent bah les Caucasiens, c'estàd
ceux qui étaient pas hispaniqu
ou noir, bah la grosse majorité c'était
c'était c'était des Russes et donc vous
intégrez à l'époque j'aiintégrais le
cette équipe là quoi en fait. Et
ça s'était plutôt plutôt très bien
passé.
Bonne protection.
Oui. Ouais. de très bonne protection.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui quels étaient
les les risques dans cette prison ? Mis
à part un coup de surin, un petit viol,
des choses comme ça ?
Bah vous avez euh des alors dans la
prison de haute sécurité, c'est c'est
c'est là où c'était le plus compliqué
parce que là les gens n'étaient pas
encore jugés. Donc quand les gens sont
pas encore jugés, ils n'ont pas du tout
le même état d'esprit que quand les gens
sont jugés parce que quand les gens sont
jugés, ils savent ils savent quand quand
ça va finir et cetera. Mais quand ils
sont pas jugés, vous avez des
comportements qui peuvent être
complètement extrêmes là. Donc il y a il
y a effectivement eu des viols, mais
vous avez des gens qui qui sont
complètement shootés, qui sort qui
reviennent qui sont pris dans la rue et
qui arrivent en prison et qui sont
complètement euh hors sol quoi, qui et
donc il y a eu par exemple ils ont mis
un jeune de de 20 ans qui venait de de
la rue comme ça qui venait d'arrêter.
Ils l'ont mis avec quelqu'un de 73 ans
et le jeune de 20 ans a violé le papi de
73 ans quoi, pendant la nuit. Donc vous
voyez, c'est c'est des gens qui sont qui
n'ont plus
plus tout leur tête quoi. C'est c'est
clair. Donc après vous il y a des
bagarres, il y a des il y a tout ce que
vous tout ce que vous pouvez imaginer
dans dans dans ces prisons-là.
Mais bon, il y a aussi beaucoup de de
solidarité, ça je vraiment assister
là-dessus. beaucoup de solidarité entre
le entre les prisonniers euh même
terhnie parce que il y a ces trois
groupes he donc les blancs, les les
noirs et les les hispaniques. Beaucoup
de solidarité en entre les trois. Euh en
fait, vous avez vraiment deux clans
quoi. Vous avez les prisonniers et les
matons quoi. En fait, c'est c'est c'est
c'est ça ça. Mais c'est vrai qu'il y a
des frictions, c'est vrai qu'il y a des
qu' y a des bagarres, c'est vrai qu' il
y a tout ça.
La bouffe à l'américaine ?
Bah non, c'est même pas à l'américaine.
Si encore c'était à l'américaine.
Là, pendant les les premiers 14 mois là
dans cette présente de sécurité euh je
savais pas ce que je mangeais, sauf
trois fois par mois où on avait une
cuisse de poulet. Donc euh bon, je
savais que ça ça ressemblait à une
cuisse du poulet quoi. Donc à part ça,
c'était une espèce de bouilli à chaque
fois et euh alors ça change ça chang un
peu tous les jours. Mais euh ouais donc
ce sont des prisons euh ce sont des
prisons privées et donc
c'est un business
c'est un business donc c'est c'est un
business donc si vous voulez ils
réduisent les coûts au maximum euh et
donc vous devez acheter tout. Vous devez
acheter votre verre pour de l'eau, vous
avez tout tout tout au sandal. Euh dans
cette dans cette première prison, il y
avait même pas de distributeur d'eau.
Donc euh donc tous les jours, ils
appelaient ils apportaient un bac de
glaçon. Euh et donc on devait prendre
les glaçons avec notre verre et ensuite
il y avait un distributeur d'eau euh
bouillante et euh on devait faire fondre
les glaçons avec l'eau bouillante et
donc mais il y avait pas d'eau, juste
pas d'eau. C'était que et quand il y
avait plus de glaçon, il y avait plus
d'eau. Voilà. Et donc euh
voilà et après dans dans la dans dans la
deuxème prison euh par exemple toutes
les tâches étaient faites par les par
les prisonniers.
Donc comme ce sont des prisons privées,
euh il euh le personnel est vraiment
minimum, donc ce sont que les gardiens.
Euh et après euh toute la nourriture est
préparée par les par les prisonniers,
les nettoyages, tout est nettoyé par les
prisonniers, tout tout tout. D'accord.
Euh alors euh à un moment je me suis
posé la question parce que je me suis
dit comment euh est-ce que ils peuvent
forcer les gens à travailler en prison
parce que vous êtes condamné à prison,
vous êtes pas condamné au travaux forcé
euh et on n pas normalement on n pas
droit de vous obliger à travailler
mais là vous étiez obligé de travailler
et le salaire euh parce qu'il vous paye
12 c de l'heure. Donc moi, je
travaillais 5 jours par semaine, 5h par
jour euh et ma feuille de paye à la fin
du mois, c'était 10 dollars. D'accord.
Donc et vous étiez obligé de le faire.
D'accord. Et donc je me suis posé la
question, je me suis dit "Mais comment
est-ce que dans aux États-Unis ils
peuvent imposer à des prisonniers de de
travailler et d'être payés euh ça euh et
euh d'autant plus que dans cette dans
cette deuxième prison, c'était que des
étrangers donc en fait des gens qui
n'avait pas le droit de travailler aux
États-Unis parce qu'ils beaucoup étaient
là parce qu'ils étaient euh justement en
situation illégale quoi. Donc il s'ils
étaient dehors, ils n'avaient pas le
droit de travailler mais à l'intérieur
ils étaient obligés de travailler. Et
donc je me suis posé un peu la question
donc j'ai j'ai regardé un peu les textes
de loi là-bas et euh j'ai trouvé la
réponse et ben je vous la donne en 1000.
Tiens, votre avis pourquoi est-ce que
comment ils arrivent à obliger des
personnes à travailler ? Aucune idée.
Réduction de peine ?
Non non non, c'est le 16e amendement de
la de la constitution américaine qui
abolit l'esclavage sauf dans la prison.
Donc en fait euh son tout le monde est
considéré comme esclave dans les prison.
Ouais. dans les prisons et donc dans
même dans certaines prisons en fait il
ne vous paye même pas quoi.
Châtiment corporel si vous travaillez
pas.
Alors ils appellent ça la dièel
thérapie. Alors diesel thérapie
c'estàdire que si vous travaillez pas il
vous transfert de prison en prison et
tous les deux jours il vous chang de
prison. Donc vous faites le tour des
États-Unis tous les voilà jusqu'à tant
que vous en avez marre quoi. Et donc
vous êtes tout constamment constamment
euh transféré.
C'est ça peut être assimilé à de la
torture. Oh
bah oui oui bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr.
Oui.
D'autres choses à rajouter sur les
conditions d'incarcération ? Bon, on on
rencontre beaucoup de gens euh aussi euh
extrêmement euh sympathiques parce que
vous avez des gens qui sont aussi dans
dans Ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
je suis pas un cas unique. Il y a les
prisons américaines sont plein de gens
comme moi. euh aux États-Unis euh
lorsque vous êtes mis en examen sur 100
personnes mises en examen, vous en avez
90 qui plaît de coupable parce que les
peines de prison sont tellement comme je
l'ai expliqué au début sont tellement
disproportionnées par rapport au fait
que euh les gens plaident coupables même
s'ils ne sont pas coupables simplement
pour avoir une réduction de peine
importante et sur les 10 qui vont au
procès, vous en avez 8,5 qui perdent.
Donc à partir du moment où vous êtes mis
en examen, vous avez 98,5 % de chance de
finir en repris. Donc c'est stalinien
comme comme euh comme statistique. Et
donc euh vousz vous vous retrouvez avec
beaucoup de gens qui sont euh qui sont
là. Mais euh je peux vous donner un
exemple qui qui est complètement
ahurissant. Il y avait une personne, un
mexicain qui avait été
euh euh qui avait été qui avait passé du
temps en prison pour des affaires de
drogue, qui ensuite qui avait été à la
fin de sa peine qui était retourné au
Mexique donc qui avait été expulsé
normal
et il avait vécu au Mexique pendant
plusieurs années. Et un jour, il a
décidé de prendre l'avion entre Mexico
City et Bogota. Euh et donc il devait
prendre l'avion sur Avianka, il s'est
retrouvé sur Delta Airen parce que
c'était un coacher. Et lorsque le pilote
a vu sur ce manifeste que c'était un
ex-prisonnier, il a averti la tour de
contrôle à Bogota comme quoi dans son
avion, il avait un ex prisonnier
américain et il a été arrêté à Bogota,
renvoyé aux États-Unis et il a pris un
an de prison pour reentry on US parce
qu'il était retourné sur le territoire
américain parce qu'il avaient pris un
avion d'altraen entre Mexico City et
Bogota.
Et donc vous retrouvez avec des gens
comme ça. C'est complètement ahurissant.
Bon, on va passer aux questions on va
prendre la première. Que pensez-vous de
la privatisation d'ADP ?
Alors, moi je comprends pas pourquoi on
privatise ADP déjà. Euh donc, j'en pense
tout le mal pas en penser.
Christine Lagarde, vous vous en pensez
quoi ?
Euh
je trouve qu'elle s'en est très bien
sortie dans euh
dans l'affaire tapis. Euh maintenant, je
pense que c'est euh je pense que c'est
une personne qui est quand même qui est
de qui est de grande valeur
qui travaille pour les Américains. Non.
Euh alors je sais pas, on va voir ce
qu'elle on va voir ce qu'elle va faire
euh à la Commission européenne. Euh
moi
je demande à voir. Je demande à voir. Ça
va être intéressant de de voir ce que
comment elle va comment elle va faire
ses premiers mois. Euh
moi plutôt intéressé d'avoir d'avoir une
quand même une française à la tête euh
de la BCE. Maintenant, il faut voir
comment ça va ça va le faire. Mais bon,
on veut pas jeter la pierre avant
d'avoir vu. Les gens changent. Les gens
changent. Moi, je pense beaucoup que les
gens changent. Et des gens qui étaient
euh très atlantiste Bah, la prison ça
fait changer les gens.
Elle a pas fait de prison elle.
Ouais, mais elle a peut-être pas fait de
prison. Et peut-être que euh
je pense que il y a beaucoup de gens
aussi qui qui n'ont peut-être pas
compris ce qui s'était passé
euh
non non pas avec Tapis de manière
générale avec les États-Unis. Cette
guerre cette guerre économique et
l'utilisation du droit comme arme de
guerre économique, je pense que certes
dans des milieux euh comme les vôtres,
les gens sont au courant mais la plupart
des gens ne sont pas sont pas au
courant. Je pense que même au niveau des
des politiques, il y en a beaucoup qui
qui le sont et qui je suis d'accord avec
vous peut-être euh le font par intérêt,
mais je pense qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
ont qui ont pas compris la mesure de du
problème. Et donc je donne bénéfices de
doute à pas mal de monde. Peut-être je
suis peut-être un peu naïf, mais euh
à voir à voir.
Comment vous voyez la le comment vous
percevez le système financier mondial ?
Est-ce que c'est un système financier
qui est overstetch, hypertendu ? Est-ce
que c'est un système financier qui est
totalement stable ? Est-ce que c'est un
système financier qui a des pieds
d'argile ? Est-ce que c'est un système
financier qui n'est plus tenable ?
Est-ce que le monde financier
euh n'est pas devenu complètement
schizophrène ? N'est pas devenu
complètement
Je pense que les l'ultra
financiérisation de a conduit à ce que
ce que nous avons en France. 10 % de
chômage et cetera, une déconnexion de
avec les valeurs euh
humaines complètes. Donc moi je pas
jeter la pierre au système financier,
mais ce qu'il faut c'est c'est c'est que
le rendre beaucoup plus humain et
beaucoup plus au service de des des
citoyens. Là ce qu'on ce que nous voyons
actuellement c'est c'est
l'ultralibéralisme et ça ça il faut que
ça s'arrête à un moment. On le voit de
toute façon les gens ne se reconnaissent
plus dans ce dans ce système là. Euh on
le voit avec les gilets jaunes, on le
voit ce que regardez ce qui se passe à
Bfort. Regardez, ne serait-ce que euh
sur le projet que je porte là de de
racheter euh le nucléaire, le fait que
nous n'ayons pas nous n'ayons pas de
fond de pension en France euh digne de
de de ce nom, c'est quand même un
problème souverain
de fonds souverains ou même de fonds de
pension, de de de fonds français
qui peuvent investir à à long terme. Le
problème, c'est le court termisme. Dans
tout ça,
pas de cap. Mais a il y a tout le monde
regarde demain. Or sur ces sujets là, il
faut regarder le long terme.
Ceux qui ceux qui font du long terme
sont les Chinois actuellement. Alors
ils ont toujours fait mais mais au moins
ça ça a certaines vertus. Alors certes
le système politique est perfectible
là-bas mais au moins avoir une vision
long terme sur beaucoup de choses ça ça
aide. Là on est dans le court terme tout
le temps là ce que ce que nos politiques
à quoi il pensent maintenant. et penser
au prochain au municipal dans dans 12
mois. C'est tout. C'est tout. Donc tout
ce qui ne va pas aller dans le sens euh
des municipal et cetera va être va ne va
pas
aboutir à des décisions qu'on qu'on
devrait pour autant prendre. C'est ça le
risque.
Vous avez un avis sur les gilets jaunes
?
Je comprends je comprends je comprends
euh
cette réaction. Euh
je pense que on n'est pas fini. Euh si
on vous regardez ce qui se passe à Bfort
euh avec 1000 suppressions d'emplois
censé cré
alors que ça était censé en créer créer
1000 euh on on se rend compte qu'on a
été euh complètement floué. Euh
à Bellefort, il y a deux urgences. Il y
a une urgence sociale et une urgence
stratégique avec le nucléaire parce que
l'usine, elle est là-bas. D'accord.
Mais on peut pas résoudre ça avec un
coup de baguette magique. Tant qu'on a
pas de politique industrielle à long
terme et cetera, on va faire du coup à
coup et c'est ce que nous faisons
actuellement. On fait en essayant de
faire le pompier à chaque fois. À chaque
fois qu'il y a un problème, on va
essayer de faire le pompier. Je vous
rappelle qu'avant BF, il y a quand même
eu 250 licenciements à Grenoble aussi
dans l'hydraulique. Euh et il va y en
avoir encore sur d'autres sites bien
évidemment. Donc où est la politique
industrielle en France ? Euh il y en a
plus. C'est ça le c'est ça le
si il y a une politique industrielle en
France, c'est vendre tout à la découpe.
Est-ce que vous avez la même perception
que moi qui est euh vous savez quand
l'excion soviétique c'est c'est vautré
euh tout leurs florons sont fait euh
découper et il y a des gens qui sont
beaucoup enrichis. Hm
hm.
Est-ce qu'on on peut faire la même chose
? On peut on peut faire le parallèle
avec ce qui se passe avec la France.
Alors, peut-être pas dans les mêmes
proportions, mais mais il y a eu
beaucoup il y a eu énormément de vent.
Mais mais tant qu'on a pas défini ce que
ce que sont les industries stratégiques,
tant qu'on a pas défini cette politique,
ça n'est mieux personne. Regardez quand
même sur cette affaire d'Alstom, avant
Alstom, il y a quand même une totale
technique Palcatel et cetera. Qui en a
entendu parler ? Personne. Personne
personne personne n'en a parlé alors que
ces entreprises ont été ponctionné de
centaines de millions de de dollars.
Milliard.
Ouais. Après milliards, mais on a pas
entendu parler. Il y a fallu qu' que les
Américains aillent trop loin parce que
là je pense qu'ils sont allés trop loin
avec le rachat d'Alsom pour qui est
quand même
c'était trop gros.
C'était un peu trop gros mais mais tant
qu'il tant tant qu'il gagne il joue. Euh
là on en parle maintenant en 2019 mais
ça s'est passé quand ? S'est passé en
2014 il y a déjà 5 ans et en 5 ans, on a
perdu beaucoup de temps aussi a beaucoup
de temps. On le voit de de plus en plus.
Oui
oui, je peux plus.
Autre question d'internet. Pour faire
face au soft power américain, faut-il
fermer la French French American
Foundation ?
Ouais, je pense que ça ch ça ça ne
changera pas grand-chose. Euh je pense
qu'il faut surtout une prise de
conscience euh française et des
politiques qui ont euh le courage de
leurs de leurs convictions et qu'ils
passent aux actes. Surtout passer aux
actes. Le problème c'est on on parle, on
fait des rapports, on fait des
préconisations et cetera et cetera. On
n'agit pas derrière. On nagit pas tant
que encore une fois tant qu'on aura pas
montré la notre propre force ils vont
continuer à jouer et tant qu'on aura pas
défini nos priorité ils vont continuer à
jouer tant qu'on aura pas racheté
les industries souveraines elles vont
continuer à jouer et cetera et ça va
continuer. Il faut agir faut surtout
agir.
Vous êtes moins béliqueux que moi. C'est
dommage.
Ouais on peut je sais pas.
Autre question internet. Que pensent-il
des six élus récemment nommés à l'Union
européenne ? La garde fait en en fait
partie. Euh est-ce qu'il travaille pour
les Américains ? Question d'internet.
Bon, ça on a déjà parlé tout à l'heure
de de la garde.
Est-ce que vous pensez que la
privatisation d'ADP est poussée par les
Américains ?
Je
non, je pense pas. Enfin, je pense que
on a pas besoin de pousser sur parfois
sur ce sujet là. On on fait des bêtises
nous-mêmes. Surtout pas l'intérêt de de
privatiser AADP.
Euh
la Française des Jeux, mince. Alors,
pourquoi on privatise la Française des
jeux ?
Bon, c'est entreprise profitable. Donc
on a déjà vu lorsqu'on a privatisé les
les autoroutes
et beaucoup de choses. Je vois pas
l'intérêt. Je vois pas l'intérêt.
Alors, autre question internet. Que vous
suggère le manque de soutien à votre
égard du gouvernement français ?
Euh
je dirais que le le problème c'est pas
moi quoi. Euh qu'il m'est pas soutenu.
Bon à la limite euh
c'est c'est pas c'est pas si grave que
ça. Qui n'est pas qui n'est pas soutenu
Alstom. C'est surtout ça le le problème
c'est qu'on est laissé euh vendre Alom à
Genè électrique alors qui euh moi
j'étais qu'un pion là-dedans. J'ai
utilisé à faire à faire peur c'est tout.
Euh mais euh moi je pense que ce piège
se referme sur tout le monde. Ce piège
se referme sur les individus comme on
l'a vu avec moi. Ce piège se referme sur
les entreprises.
Ce ce piège se referme sur les patrons
d'entreprise. Parce que lorsque vous
négociez avec un fusil sur la temp soit
vous vendez la boîte, soit vous allez 15
ans en toll, ben vous vendez la boîte.
Euh ce piège se referme sur sur le
gouvernement euh qui est pas toujours au
courant de ce que l'entreprise fait
parce que l'entreprise veut faire ça un
accord à Katimini avec le département of
justice. Donc euh
c'est un piège très très bien huilé en
fait hein. C'est un piège très très bien
huilé et c'est difficile de de de
pointer le doigt sur des personnes et
cetera.
D'où d'où le nom de votre bouquin le
piège américain.
Voilà.
Alors autre question d'internet. Euh,
bougez pas, il faut juste que je remonte
ma petite ligne.
Alors, que pensent-il des diverses
tentatives de privatisation actuelle ?
Est-ce que ça annonce une crise
financière ? Est-ce que l'État français
est-il sur les rotules ?
Bah, l'État français est sur les rotules
depuis pas mal de temps déjà. Euh mais
c'est pas une raison non plus.
Qui disait que il était à la tête d'un
d'un état en fait.
Ouai. Oui. Euh mais c'est pas une raison
non plus pour euh pour faire n'importe
quoi euh derrière. Donc euh
non, ben je autant je pense qu'il y a
des peut-être des des entreprises à
privatiser euh mais autant encore une
fois pour revenir sur ADP, je vois pas
l'intérêt quoi.
Euh euh et une question, une dernière
question internet. Que pensent-t-il des
questions sur l'effondrement du système
financier ?
Bah pour l'instant, il s pas il effondré
encore le système financier. Euh moi je
doute que ça n'arrive. On a il essayé
d'effondrer en 2008 euh ben il était
très vite remis sur pied
euh
d'argent public
euh et donc qui ont dont les grandes les
grandes banques et grandes compagn
américaines ont profité et qui derrière
c'est nous qui avons subi ces foudres
là. Encore une fois,
on a une vue en en France extrêmement
euh euh biaisé des des choses. Euh on
accuse les Russes, les Chinois et cetera
et cetera, mais on voit pas ce que font
les Américains. Euh
c'est quand même eux qui ont créé la
plus grosse crise financière.
Derrière, on n pas on n pas réagi. Tout
le monde en a payé les conséquences.
C'est quand même eux qui ont fait les
plus grosses campagnes d'espionnage au
monde là.
euh on est inquiet peut-être que les
Chinois mettent des puces et cetera.
Bien sûr, on est inquiet que les Russes
mettent des pulces et cetera, mais eux
qui ont avoué à fait avoir fait des
campagnes de de d'espionnage, personne
ne leur dit rien. Euh, on a plus
d'indépendance, on est on a perdu notre
indépendance complètement sur ce
sujet-là. On est complètement, je pense,
vassalisé et on va on on donne le crédit
à chaque fois au même.
Euh, est-ce que vous avez trois bouquins
à conseiller à notre communauté ? Ouh là
! Trois bouquins. Alors
oui, mais sur des sujets un peu variés
déjà euh déjà sur sur mon sujet, je
pense que euh Ali Lai que vous
connaissez peut-être qui a écrit un très
bon livre sur euh sur justement
l'extratériorité des des lois
américaines.
Euh lui, il a fait un un travail, on va
dire, plus didactique en reprenant à peu
près tout toutes les lois en expliquant
comment elles ont été utilisées dans le
passé. Donc ça, je vous le conseille, je
vous le conseille.
Après, il y a un livre qui m'a beaucoup
touché ces derniers temps euh et j'avais
pas pu le lire au moment où il était
sorti.
C'est le livre de Guillan Watrelo qui a
perdu sa famille dans le dans le vol
MH370
euh qui est très touchant euh parce que
euh là encoreù il atterit,
on sait pas, on sait pas où il atterri
mais surtout le combat de cet homme m'a
beaucoup touché. Donc ça, alors je vous
je vous le conseille, je vous conseille
ça sa lecture. Euh
après qu'est-ce que j'ai lu récemment
qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup touché ? Euh
alors, il y a euh
un livre de Naomi Klein qui s'appelle
The Chock Therapy,
stratégie du choc.
La stratégie du choc. Excellent livre.
Alors là qui reprend en fait toutes les
grandes crises euh dans le monde euh
toutes les lois néolibérale passe après.
Voilà. Excellent livre. Excellent livre.
Alors en français, je connais pas le
titre parce que je stratégie du choc.
La stratégie du choc. Voilà. Choc puis
voilà. Exactement.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil aux
jeunes générations ?
Alors moi je suis très content parce que
là je je je vais très souvent dans les
écoles et euh je vois beaucoup beaucoup
de jeunes qui s'intéressent à c c ces
sujets-là. Euh et donc euh oui euh à
chaque fois mon conseil c'est c'est le
même, c'est soyez curieux parce que
voilà, ça c'est la base de tout. Essayez
de comprendre ce qui se passe autour de
vous. Euh je pense que c'est c'est
vraiment la euh la base de
l'intelligence, c'est comprendre.
Essayer de comprendre. Soyez curieux et
ne soyez pas naïfs. Euh et donc je vois
de plus en plus, je suis très très
positif en fait sur cette nouvelle
génération. Je vois qu'ils sont beaucoup
connaissent beaucoup plus de choses que
qu'on voudrait le faire croire et il
s'intéresse notamment à ces sujets là.
Je vois énormément de jeunes j'ai été
contacté par plein plein de personnes
alors via les réseaux sociaux et cetera
depuis que le livre est sorti et qui
sont vraiment passionnés par ces sujets.
Frédéric Pirucci, merci.
C'est moi qui vous remercie.
[Musique]